i like a good three two one i don't know
if you uh if you like one of those but i
like those
cameras be nice being queued up once in
a while we're live
all right and we're live wow we are live
on the
bet david podcast i am not patrick bet
david although
i'm gonna attempt to be him today pat is
traveling he's out of town he said what
tom
the show must go on next man up and look
at us now
we got tom and his standard seat we got
kai got
pulled out of the bullpen he's in my
seat i'm in pat's seat
guy how does it feel to your talent now
bro how does it feel i've always been
talented so i'm always
dead i'm ready to be here
22 cut with that this is podcast number
41.
podcast number 40 almost every single
one i've never not sat in there okay
so you probably an eye in this one give
it a roll today but but this guy over
here i think he's been waiting for this
opportunity you know
i don't know i know you remember last
week i know
he stepped up last week yeah but dad's
not in town now you can say whatever you
want
dad's not in town it's party time
no but respect to pat he said listen we
got a good thing going on here i'm
traveling when i travel
you know we can't just stop the podcast
so shout out to
all the valuetainers watching pat we'll
be back don't worry for the uh
for the community out there that maybe
is not digging this vibe we know you are
it's all good
the show will go back to normal but we
respect you we want to keep the
the party going and we want to keep you
informed and uh
tom thoughts well just in general before
we dive in you know i think the bottom
line and the great thing about this
podcast
is there's always great topics and
there's so many good things going on now
that the audience loves that there's no
reason not to do this we could clearly
do it every day if we wanted to
so eventually hopefully we'll be doing
well he's easy every day relax
relax you wouldn't want to do that okay
podcast every day down the road
but great stuff today too yes and you
know our friends in texas you know still
freezing and i think we can get thinking
of our friends in texas right
man you just don't expect that you know
texas has been branded and portrayed as
this
over-the-top progressive state that
everybody wants to get through with no
flaws
no issues no problems and this isn't a
minor speed bump or something this is
something that they have to
face down the road and really figure out
how they're going to fix this thing you
got some strong feelings on text well
you know what i
i have family there i have friends there
and i would only imagine what it would
be like to be in that situation
personal chef in texas yeah my uncle my
wife's uncle
was my personal chef he would make me a
breakfast sandwich every single morning
every morning either phenomenal
shout out bill coxton do you miss texas
before we get into the topics
you know because we i don't i think that
people know we are now in boca raton
florida
uh we got eric galera back there paula
scarcel sam doing the ones and twos
and just before we get started we'll get
back to you kai let's just give a shout
out to mario over here
he is representing pbd he's got his eyes
focusing on us he's not going to i'm
today clap it up for mario everybody
he is holding it down thank you respect
to mario
if you if you appreciate mario standing
in for pbd
give me a thumbs up over there is that
like adam is standing in the people well
you know but you're
the audience wants to know what's on
your mind so things are on my mind kai
tee it up for you before we get to the
topic
texas i totally miss texas i do i love
no i love i love the uh the non
uh one degree fahrenheit weather uh and
i don't know if you guys have seen the
picture where
you have uh over all of america right
now it's like na
it's like one degree three degrees five
degrees ten degrees and then you see the
one part in florida where it's like
seven yeah fahrenheit
i'm sweating i came in sweating this
morning and you weren't even biking to
work
i wasn't even biking i didn't even walk
to work my uber did not have
his ac i got a buddy what do you what's
going on here so anyway that's what's
going on with pat we're thinking of you
pat
he's traveling i think he's in kentucky
right now yep he's in kentucky
shout out to uh matt zappala moneysmart
guy he's doing an event there
so i hope that goes well they're with
tim tebow legendary
what's he doing he announced it today
he's done with baseball he's stopped
he's going to stop pursuing the dream
maybe he broke it last night at the
event i was going to say do you think
pat or sapal or anyone php
had some influence and uh and tebow's
saying screw it i'm going all business
now
well maybe they had some influence in
him announcing it or or being public you
know on a forum there where he could
actually say it so he was the lead
speaker
or the uh at the event yesterday and
today he broke the news that he's done
with the sports club well the news broke
i don't know if he actually had a press
conference maybe it came out of last
night but yeah tebow's done he was
chasing that dream in baseball just like
he did in football you got to give him
credit well he married a
supermodel he's a south african
supermodel so i think he's going to be
all right bro
does that just call uh you know cure
every ill just every single if you can
marry a supermodel it's not a bad it's
not about never it never worked for tom
brady why would it work for him
he's a stud though yeah tom brady worked
it worked out okay for him but you heard
about what's going on with tom brady
right now
obviously last week he got schwasted he
was throwing the lombardi
trophy across a boat whatever now
apparently there's a petition we know
about the gavin newsom petition but now
there's a petition for him to return
what like almost a million dollars of
ppp loans have you heard about this
the brady organization have you heard of
this well yeah i heard that he got the
loan
you know with his with his business with
this company he has a legit business i
mean it's not like some
tv yeah okay so it's legit i mean with
supplements and all the merch that they
sell and everything
but really people are trying to get him
to guys guys you know tom brady's
struggling right now
you know he's he's he's down on his luck
times are tough
and he's going after that ppp loan and
they wanted to return it but you know
one thing
tom brady should have to return because
it's a separate thing it's not tom
brady's money it was for the business a
legit business that they used probably
for
realistic you know reasons and i don't
think i mean why should
just because he's super successful and
really rich should he be immune from his
business which is a completely separate
entity
i'm sure it's not like he's just you
know funding it every single day i'm
sure he wants that thing to live on its
own
i think you should be separate and if it
you know if it qualified for a loan
right legally
they should be able to get it like any
other business 160
000 signatures already in how many days
i don't know how long it's been up let's
see all right
there's kai doing the research mario
where were you on that one bro
no comment everybody everybody was like
who's tom brady
everybody that signed it is a buffalo
bill fan a miami fan yeah
drew brees might have been leading that
truck former patriots all right let's
get into the topics
today and um here we go let's get down
to the to business
bet david podcast episode 41 here's
what's on the agenda
today the roll the roll call look out
netflix
those big mouse ears in your rear view
mirror are closer than they appear
that's disney plus coming after netflix
uh insiders at covid 19 vaccine makers
sold nearly a half a billion dollars of
stock
last year as the stock was going up boom
sell we'll get into that
shout out to our new york friends out
there manhattan and brooklyn
new lease signings surge in january
so it looks like people are getting back
to new york that's exciting stuff we'll
get into that verizon climbs four
percent
after legendary investor warren buffett
reveals 9 billion dollar
investment into verizon four percent
here's a big story facebook meets apple
in clash of the titans quote unquote
from zuck
we need to inflict pain pretty intense
i went russian with that actually you
did you went it was a putin thing you
know
anyway uh apple could soar prediction
here apple could source 66
in bowl case scenario as it searches for
a golden partnership to build
electric vehicles kai i know that you
know coming from norway you've got some
major thoughts on
evs in the news today this might be our
top story robin hood ceo
vlad tenef is reportedly staying at a
hotel
instead of going home after receiving
death threats he's on capitol hill
today testifying
for everything that happened in the
gamestop reddit wall street bets saga so
we'll get into that
speaking of that big short investor
michael burry says the tesla boom
is remarkably similar to the dot-com and
housing bubbles if there's anybody that
would know about that
it's him um getting back to the europe
stuff ford's
uh europe car line up to be all electric
by 2030. same with jaguar's land rover
car range before electric by 2030.
so they're thinking electric could
happen in the next 10 fully electric
within the next
10 years kyle you'll be like 31 at that
point priming your career you're just
getting started
driving an electric vehicle yeah stud
stud and he's always been talented
apparently he'll be
ubering in an electrical always uber
everywhere all right here's a big story
biden did a town hall
a couple days ago and the lead story
from that is he said a lady got up and
asked him the question
i got fifty thousand dollars in student
loan debt um
would you you're gonna cancel that he
goes i will not make that happen his
number seems to be
ten grand 10 grand so we'll cover that
um
texas that we talked about uh shout out
to our friends in texas
if you're listening t granbeckien our
friend tigran beckyan
uh he is the marketing manager at php
our good friend
we did a facetime with him yesterday you
know tigran of course um
covered he said he's been out of town
out of power
really he's he's got nothing he's
facetimed us yesterday we all saw him
and uh snow everywhere it was crazy
what's going on in texas the texas grid
got crushed
because its operators didn't see the
need to prepare for cold weather
almost 3 million texans are now without
power as the state battles
an unprecedented winter storm getting
back to biden he says he would
compromise on the timing of the 15
minimum wage we covered that last
episode he might touch on that
go green save green congress looking to
save buyers seven thousand dollars on a
purchase of a new tesla
chevy cadillac or elect or another
electric vehicles
through the green act how much money
would they have to give you to go
green we'll get into that trump our good
friend trump you might remember him he
was the president for
the last four years well he ripped mitch
mcconnell
as it seems like the band-aid is off the
gloves are off
he ripped uh former house
senate i'm sorry senate majority leader
mitch mcconnell
yeah he was scorched earth on him yeah
well mcconnell went in on him
prior to that but he said um you know
we'll get into that
he said he uh we'll get some quotes for
you rush limbaugh respect
you know i was not a rush limbaugh fan
quite frankly but i do
respect the man you can respect but
don't have to like you know you did not
know who
rush limbaugh was really i don't watch
tv i don't you don't need to he's on the
radio i think he called
i don't listen to the radio like he
thought it was like lambeau field like
pacquiao he's like lambo field guy like
that's totally different guy um
but to be on the radio for 30 plus years
uh my friend
sbj uh s bag joe is literally
like crying he's that was his hero so
respect to uh
the rush limbaugh fans out there bill
gates will touch on this
rich nation should move to a hundred
percent synthetic
beef and last but not least your boy
fauci
dr anthony fauci says the us may not
have enough covert vaccines for
everybody until june
which is later than planned they thought
it was going to spring he's always got
good news doesn't he
i mean when he opens his mouth it's
something depressing you're not a fan of
fouchy
not really you know what nothing what
grade would you give him
i would give him a d plus d if that
let's get to the audience here uh
valuetainers out there
fans of the bet david podcast before we
get into the topic give a grade right
now we're going to be watching
um the comments the comment section kai
would you do it
give a grade for fauci is it an a is he
killing it is he crushing it a plus
is he more like a c student barely
getting by hey you know dee's that
get degrees baby you know we know that
that's how uh
i graduated college and that's is he an
f adam he's got failing he's got one job
okay he's not in the science room or in
the in the laboratory with a lab coat on
under a microscope he's not
curing covid19 he's not the best he has
one job
and he has failed miserably at it he
needs to update people with
legitimate consistent information that's
in tune with his boss
i.e the president he couldn't do it with
trump he can't do it with biden
okay he biden kept him on he said i mean
of course yeah he's the mascot
it's like you go to an nba game you got
the guy jumping off the trampoline and
doing the triple flip
dunk like the gorilla that's fousey's
phoenix i mean he should be he should be
wearing one of those
[Music]
let's see there's bees uh f he
flip-flops
flip-flops here's the other thing when
he speaks
when he speaks he needs to exert a
calmness he
everybody's freaked out about
coronavirus since march you listen to
him you get more freaked out
his one job i think should be to bring
hope to calm people to
encourage people and say we've got this
we're working on it the smartest minds
are involved
this is going to be tackled i mean he's
up there bumbling and stumbling and
fumbling he doesn't know what he's doing
he's
chris berman yeah they threw him into
way big way too much of a
a profile that he wasn't used to i mean
not anybody can do that he turned into a
covid back uh
rockstar well nobody knew who he was
before this and that's a lot and that's
a good thing
though yeah if you don't know who the
head of the cdc or whatever that's
probably a good thing that means you
don't have a freaking
pandemic surging right now i just think
people are looking for the solution and
easy answers from him
and he's not capable of providing that
so i think it's a d-plus kai give us an
update on the grades well i mean you you
saw the comments what kind of grades we
got going no it's mostly f
cs some b's e's okay give me give me the
bottom line
we got a five dollar donation from uh
audra saying he needs to be replaced
so i mean i think there's repeal and
replace fauci i think that's what we're
going through what it sounds like repeal
and replace fiji what's the bottom line
on the grade kai
based on everything you saw c c the d
c minus fauci fauci
okay let's talk about uh let's get into
the topics i think with the fouchy
topics uh good segue
is what's happening with these vaccine
makers let's talk about this story right
here
uh insiders at covid vaccine makers sold
nearly
500 million dollars of stock last year
executives and and directors at pfizer
moderna and other companies astrazeneca
being one of them
developing the coven 19 vaccine sold
approximately
a half a billion dollars in stock last
year
reaping rewards of positive vaccine
developments that drove up the value of
the drug maker share
in dollar terms much of the sales came
at a single company which was moderna
maker of one of the two coveted vaccines
authorized
in uh for use in the united states
executives
and directors there sold more than 320
million of their stocks that's the
majority of it
and more than 700 transactions merck
company
insiders sold 58 million of their shares
novavax executive sold more than
40 million of their shares after the
company vaccine hit milestones
in august and september and here's the
bottom line corporate compensation
experts
say these kinds of sales are the natural
consequence
of a long-term shift to using stock for
a greater share of executive pay
with the goal being to taipei to
performance in this case the development
of life-saving vaccines
this is a pretty big story mr zenner
your thoughts you know it's very clear
for me i would be
way more worried if they didn't do this
because that would just show that
they're not confident in the vaccine
i mean that's when you should be really
scared of the executives that are behind
this that putting it out there
that is going to get us back to normal
in this country let's not underestimate
what this vaccine is going to do
it's going to bring normalcy back to the
country it's going to open up the
economy even more
it's going to get the kids back into
school it's get going to get christians
and muslims and every faith back into
church
it's going to get us back into baseball
stadiums and football stadiums and nba
arenas so
why wouldn't they do that if you have
the ability to do that if they pay you
in stock options
you're with a company that is developing
the vaccine that is going to really help
save the world
cash in you know it's not illegal number
one it will always draw headlines right
because it looks like
ooh what are they up to clearly they
know something right that
that's a really loose interpretation of
insider training but it's really not
because they didn't get it from somebody
else
so you're not going inside or trading or
anything like that yeah there's nothing
that the sec or the department of
justice or anybody can do about this i
have no problem with it because they
have confidence in the vaccine
and so far you know the vaccine is being
produced and it's out there so
no no issue from me no hi you feel the
same way where are you at i don't even
consider the vaccine
like as an issue here of like they have
faith in it i'm just thinking
if you look up this stock price mario
can you bring up the stock price for
moderna look at kai baby
yeah mario on the ones that put him to
work uh what do you got
the power's already going to his head
he's already talented give me data now
uh
but if we look at here and then go all
time or max
what stock price you're looking at right
now okay
what do you got max uh time length wise
mario
uh above there right above and then a
little bit to the left
hit that one i mean the i don't need to
be an insider to know that modern is
trading at its all-time high
what are the odds that there's going to
be a new pandemic within the next few
years where
everyone in the world is relying on
their vaccine so
i mean heck yeah sell as long as they
legally can sell their stocks and
they're not
bound up in any way sell sell sell great
point young kai what is in the jedi
young what
petawan young padawan the thing you
always say i'm almost like what are you
calling me yeah but isn't it great point
right i mean there it's at an all-time
high is it an all-time high right now or
is it certain as long as it's big
that's max okay and you just look at the
stock price like dude we are killing it
right now let's go
get rid of it our compensation is tied
to the stock price that's i mean that's
part of the rules of the game
let's go here's the other thing you guys
too is you know you look at the headline
this is another one of these things
that's going to offend a lot of people
that don't understand it because they
only see 500 million and they think
people are getting rich but this
i think this is 13 separate drug
companies
all right and you're looking at a lot of
executives that get paid in stock
options so
really it's not even that much i don't
think i don't think these guys are like
having a backup i mean other than the
fact that there's 320 million
out of the half a billion coming from
modernist strictly i mean okay so
modern went all in on but they were also
the first one that got really developed
yeah so they've been at the forefront
because you've had pfizer and then
there's a few other ones but modern is
one of the big ones they've been talking
about so we've got no problem with them
cashing out here is that the
is that the uniformed opinion here but i
don't know money what do you think that
make that money bank
what is the other option i mean you
couldn't have a problem with it because
it's not illegal
number one and it's human nature and
it's common sense and it's a smart move
by them
so you think this is sort of a headline
of the day and it'll just go out the
window i think it's the type of headline
that attracts you know a lot of
questions we're talking about
we're talking about it type of headline
that attracts clicks but what else i
mean i think if you just don't like
really understand
you know the inner workings of when you
have stock options and when they're
vested and when you can use them you
wait
if you if your company's public and
you're paid in stock options or that's
part of your incentive
man you're watching the clock i mean you
are you counting down any single day
until
you can sell those things all right
because that's why you have them
you know these are talk about that talk
about that best thing period what are
your thoughts on that well um
no my thoughts you know just i know
people that have been in public
companies and they and they are
they receive a lot of stock options and
it
controls their life almost man is the
biggest thing about how many stock
options you have when are they invested
when when can i cash them in really
i mean and that's why it was funny
because we were talking about bumble the
other day right how they went public oh
we were talking about bumblebee but we
yes we were and the ceo uh whitney
heard right yeah yeah i think that is
how she told her employees
don't follow and don't monitor the stock
price and i'm just going
how can you ask them that i mean that
that is a big part of their life in the
in their future
but it's also from a different
standpoint of more a
because jeff business said said the same
thing that if the stock price goes up
ten percent that doesn't make him ten
percent smarter
or ten percent like right it only and
when he monitors
exactly so with a company like tesla as
well where the stock prices
shot up so much they're not suddenly way
better it's just that the
market is over evaluating them so you're
saying don't invest
that's their message because what are
you gonna if you the more time you're
focusing on that the less time you're
focusing on the business and actually
creating something that's gonna reflect
the market
keep your eye on the ball is what
they're basically saying don't worry
about what you know peripherals
now obviously if you're trying to secure
it and stuff like that then obviously
you don't want to sell it on a downturn
or like
when it's hitting the bottom but the
grand scheme of things you got to focus
on what's
getting you there and what can get that
up not necessarily just look at it and
hope it goes up mm-hmm
okay okay is that it is any anything
you had some thoughts on the vest thing
yesterday we were talking about
investing no it's just if there's any uh
obviously with the the insider trading
for modern and something like that if
but as long as they're properly uh in
their contracts
however long they have to hold those
stocks then obviously you can't sell
them so that would be the only got it
have you do you guys know anybody that's
been vaccinated
like yeah my mom oh yeah how'd it go for
her did you have to do the two
she got yeah double dose she's doing
great yeah multiple people
yeah i know what's funny is um i know
people that have been vaccinated a
couple of my
friends i have a friend who's a doctor
he got vaccinated
well my friend's wife is a doctor he's
like the plus one he's the plus one he
got you know he kind of got in the club
because
you know the uh he's with the dj the
doctor over there but i have multiple
friends my uncle got back i know
multiple people they got vaccinated
ironically um the one person
who says they've had some um
some fallout from this is my
brother-in-law who's a dentist
he's like i would not get vaccinated it
ain't happening like he's just sort of
on that on that side of the equation
but he said a couple of people that work
in in his office a hygienist you know
healthcare workers that quote unquote
they all had bad reactions to this he's
sort of like uh
uh yeah you know uh finding faults yeah
exactly
so what what about where were you going
with that no i you know and eric can
probably uh
speak on this i heard what 33 of the
military is refusing it
right 30 to 33 percent i haven't heard
anything but
i've never seen anybody being able to
successfully refuse oh really
okay if they're refusing it i i wonder
what their you know the law
ramifications are yeah great insight
from our former
uh marine eric galera now eric you're
saying that in the military if they say
you're getting a shot
you're getting a shot yeah there's
there's no question
if they tell you to do something you do
it even a shot you signed the contract
yes
they tell you to move they tell you to
do this they tell you to get a shot
that's part of it yes
so i mean i'm sure with good lawyers you
can probably fight it
but i i can see it being a very
difficult thing to so when you were in
the military
um marine because you're a reserve now
right
they said hey buddy you got to go get
this shot this show that shot you said
yeah
no question right so with the vaccine
right now you don't think that there's
any truth to the story that 33 no no
and maybe now with this being a
different situation there's
you know lawyers trying to back up these
people
but in my experience before covet
i've never seen anybody successfully not
get a shot because they didn't want to
get it
gotcha that's our former marine eric
alera guys weighing in
on the equation mario would you get the
covet vaccine shot if they were giving
it out would you get it
uh it depends it depends if i had to um
for whatever reason so i know people
that have taken the shot they're feeling
good i know people who are refusing it
um
extremely saying i will never allow them
to vaccinate me but
really for me it depends on on you know
circumstance
okay so personally no i mean i work with
patrick but david adam so
so what does that mean i have certain
set of beliefs okay principles and
uh shout out to patrick beth david
anytime we will give him he's commenting
in the chat right now so if you want to
talk to me is that him talking about the
soy boy stuff right there is that
packaging
all right shout out to the joy boy mafia
we're out there did you get the vaccine
yeah i have a pretty much similar uh
approach as mario does and the one thing
that scares me
is if they start mandating it for
flights
because you you hear that thrown out
there and i've got to show that you've
been vaccinated
you literally can't fly well
internationally i could probably see
that happening but they've even thrown
it out there domestically
and then they want to come up with this
electronic almost like id card that
shows
it's almost like a passport it's like a
health passport where you can show that
have a barcode scan shows that i was
vaccinated i just don't think that's the
path we want to go do you get the
vaccine
uh i'm kind of depending on what's
needed and what's what you can
or can't do without it uh but with the
vaccine card i mean
i'd be surprised because if if they're
able to
in uh put in a system like that because
as much as we have things now if you
think of like the efficiency of the
government
and how they can track things and keep
control of things it's like
um just updating addresses and how slow
things like that
are and go i have a hard time
uh seeing that they'll be able to create
some sort of big brother
system for how to track it overnight
instantly
where they're saying that the government
is inefficient yeah and okay
guys in the comments section i want to
know uh yes
if you would get the vaccine and know if
you would not do it paul you got to
weigh in on this where you at buddy
yeah actually there's a movie that
actually has this scenario called
songbird actually came out i believe in
april may uh michael bay produced it but
uh very similar circumstances
that tom was describing you know
scanning and you can only get in
only the vaccinated people can get in
certain places and all that stuff but
uh if you need someone to get it done
hire a movie crew you know they got
special effects guys and visual effects
guys that
they'll make it happen they'll make what
happens they'll build a set uh sure
they'll they'll they'll figure out the
whole system
some of the creative paul worked in
hollywood for a while he's a big movie
guy now he's running valuetainment he is
the i i called you
uh our lead editor the other day and you
and
you you checked me
true that but you g checked me what's
your title uh director of production
director of production i called him lead
editor and he
he verbally [ __ ] slapped me and he said
hey buddy all right so in the comments
section what do we got going on here we
got
notes yes a lot of no's a lot of no's
yeah a lot of no's
or something okay here's the question
guys before we move topics
how much money would someone have to pay
you today to get vaccinated
today money in your pocket today i want
to know in the comment section
how much some all the no's out there how
much would someone have to pay you mario
how much money is it gonna end up in
your pocket
to get vaccinated today what's the
number they can't buy me for a vacation
they can't
buy me love what about i'm for sale nine
grand
nine grand 9k not even 10.
why not give me nine he's a dirty dirty
40 people he's from california yeah okay
kai how much money
uh i'm gonna outdo uh tom and say
nine thousand and one dollars nine
thousand kai's net worth just doubled
ladies and gentlemen congratulations
right bob barker
yeah i mean if we're playing uh price's
right rules i've got to go
uh you know i'm gonna go
nine 9999 wow one dollar dollar less
under the limit
they'll tax you they'll have to claim on
taxes how much you how much would
someone have to pay you today to get
vaccinated
you know now that i've found out that we
we we have a choice you got a choice now
baby
it's america then i'm asking for 50 g's
you know geez
straight up i would do it just for a
free uber ride there we go
i'm in my uber today you screwed me bro
no ac you're driving around in south
florida you got no ac
like he's showing up to the bet david
podcast to fill in for the man pbd and
you got no ac so
the car is not equipped with it or he it
was i got an ac
problem okay i go uh
yeah you're gonna have a tip we're gonna
have a rating problem home slice
kai what do we got on on the comment
section five ounces of gold
in bitcoin okay a little bit all over
the place yeah but
10k no money gotcha so speaking of the
big brother
uh because we were going there with with
this let's talk about
this main story right here facebook
meets apple in the clash of the tech
titans i mean are there two bigger
companies in the world right now
like straight up apple and facebook
what's uh what's
amazon maybe right yeah obviously not
for sure okay but
two of the biggest companies in the
world and zuck quote unquote says we
need to inflict pain here's the story
when facebook was embroiled in
controversy over its
data collection practices tim cook in a
national television interview said
that his own company would never have
found itself
in such a jam zuck shot back
to cook's comments saying saying they
were extremely glib
and not aligned with the truth and in
private zuck was even harsher he says
we need to inflict pain can i get the
italian accent of that
i don't do italians okay i got you we
need to inflict pain on this guy
that's where you're going with that we
need to inflict pain he told his team
in private how'd that get out in the
public we can address that
facebook and apple's visions are
diverging and increasingly
incompatible facebook wants to capture
and monetize eyeballs listen up now
facebook wants to capture and monetize
eyeballs
on every possible device and platform
apple on the other hand wants to draw
users to its own
hardware centric universe partly by
marketing itself as a private
focused company underline that i'm sorry
a privacy
focused company last summer apple
announced the app tracking transparency
tool
which once rolled out will
allow ad tracking only if consumers
opt in when they receive a prompt on an
iphone or ipad
the change means that facebook and other
companies would no longer be able to id
to collect a person's advertising
identifier
without permission and in the face of
pushback from facebook and others apple
delayed the rollout
of this new tool for a few months but
said late last month it will arrive
early
this spring kai i know that you've got
some strong feelings on this
you're excited to address this topic
what are your thoughts
i'm definitely team apple on this one i
think privacy is something important
that a lot of us
don't even understand of how they're
able to track and how they can be in the
background and stuff like that so i
think
definitely privacy is something that we
should be more aware of
now from what i've understood on this
app you can either say
allow or don't allow so it's not like
they're completely cutting off like if
you really want facebook in the
background lurching
to see who's clicking allow so they can
i don't know we'll see
what did you do to my phone yesterday we
clicked allow no no we clicked not
allowed
no no we you you got it mixed you
clicked you allowed me
it was it was not allowed and then we
allowed it why would you allow that
because then you can get better ads
they can monetize you i'm coming after
you but uh but yeah you finish yourself
so yes i'm definitely more on apple's
side here i think um
the only argument that i know facebook
is making is that small businesses
will have a harder time targeting people
because you don't have the same
uh actions you're thinking of small
businesses right now that's what they're
that's the card they're playing
that who facebook yes what other card do
they have no that they're creepy and
just
watching you in the background would you
call it would you call it what was the
announcement
it's like a creepy old uncle at a at a
at a children's uh birthday party or
something like that where you have you
used quinceanera yesterday yeah
exactly the point is it's creepy exactly
because that's what you're that's the
analogy for facebook
yeah because they're creeping they're
they're creeping in the background
creeping on the camera seeing what
all this stuff like that and i think for
most people we're not even aware of it
and something like that is they're
selling the data just like crazy trying
to make so kai is coming out he's saying
he is on team apple i'm on team privacy
team privacy yes are you on kai's team
or are you
you're going somewhere else with this
time i'm not going to start agreeing
with kai i'm not
perfect my first time on a podcast i'm
not going to make him feel anymore
then he already he's already feeling too
good you know what no as a matter of
fact steal his swag
you know how dare you number one how
dare you you come on this show
thompson you have a comment like that no
i like bickering ceos number one i think
that's great for america
i think that's great for news i'd like
to see more ceos
personally whenever i see zuck v cook i
always go cook
i mean come on zach how do you root for
him right you're not i just don't
i think zuck after 10 years of being you
know full frontal on american
pop culture and tech and everything i
think you're going to be inclined to
not believe anything he says right away
that's my first
are you saying that cook is more
believable 100 percent you know 100
like like do you trust apple more or
facebook guys apple here's here's the
deal
here does anybody here not have an apple
iphone
just clara i know you know you were an
android and we had to like
convince you not so subtly to switch it
up just because
you know you you trust them more on the
surface they might be actually more
devious
yeah i mean who knows he might just be
playing us all but
but cook comes across as the non-creepy
uncle i mean he kind of comes across as
that uncle
but maybe not as creepy one more point
here you know you look at facebook
you look at apple you get some of these
other tech companies their market cap
is about equivalent to the gnp of some
countries
so you know what i think that means they
should have armies they should have
their own military
if facebook has a problem with google
they can send tanks over there
if you're looking for a hot war i mean
look this would escalate a little bit
more
um it would be interesting you got beef
with kai this morning you know here
you want to you know get these ceos and
my last point is
and i made this the other day a little
bit i think there's more room just in
general for stories like this
i think something like this or other
stories would fall by the wayside
because eighty percent of the stories in
the past were all politics we're all
trump
we're all elected he's just taking the
oxygen out of the sucking it all out of
the room so now you have the opportunity
to have these discussions where maybe
you wouldn't have heard about them
before
or maybe in actuality they're no big
deal but we get to discuss it is this a
big deal
i think facebook versus apple is a
pretty damn big dude i mean it's a big
deal but when you use the quote
we need to inflict pain yeah that's a
pretty big deal but you know what
something like that is all context too i
mean
we need to inflict pain right you don't
think you did it like hey you know like
a stalin type
what was cook thinking there man maybe
we got inflicted a little pain back i
mean it's just how you say it and but he
said it in private so like how does that
get leaked
somebody on the team is saying sounds
like facebook is doing some privacy
stuff in the
war room maybe the guy a boomer like me
didn't know how to use the thing and he
did
the young buck like you no but i mean
and i disagree with tom at one point of
of he says he'd trust facebook or apple
more because
or you don't know if we can trust apple
more one thing that comforts me is
apple makes a lot of money selling this
phone they don't need to only monetize
the data on the phone or the private
so that aspect of it i trust that
they're making i mean
thousands of dollars on the equipment
and the hardware and then you're
plugged into the ecosystems they're not
relying on the monetization of
only the data that they're selling to
monetizers however with facebook it's
free
i don't see a lot of people spending
money on like the facebook i mean they
have like the portal
and a bunch of other hardware that
they're selling but i don't see a lot of
people spending money on that kai do me
a favor
break that down in plain english what
are you saying right there you're giving
me hardware data mining
facebook probably only makes money or
mostly like 99
of their money by selling ads say that
again slowly facebook makes
money 99 of your money you said
hypothetically
okay the majority of their money by
selling ads
yes people pay money for ads ads the
more all businesses you were talking
about small businesses
probably mostly big businesses the more
ads they sell
or the more data the ads have the more
they can target the better the
geo targeting and stuff yeah geo
phishing yes there's
targets that term correctly no not at
all they'll tar though okay
however they target they can they can
choose so the more data they have
available
the better they can target that's how
they make their money which means they
need more creepy
phones anything in the background so
they can get so what you're saying
is facebook makes their money by
creeping pretty much
so listen to this stat i got a stat i
just pulled up here mario
as for the fourth quarter earnings
facebook reported 28.1 billion in
revenue of which 27.2 billion came from
ads
yes given the numbers 8.1 let me bring
this up so you guys can see it too
but and inside by mario over there
he's coming saying 90 something percent
of their money whose ads is that i don't
think that's breaking news though right
no
and with apple they're making money on
subscriptions
they're making money or they're
obviously selling phones they're selling
products
exactly hardware number four what do you
got there mario
yeah so 2020 nine percent
ninety eight percent yeah so you said
ninety nine percent you were
you were right you were right yeah i was
throwing it out there what's the percent
or two
what price is right rules you went over
oh
you're out bob barker all right what was
the quote by uh
happy girl what was the quote happy
gilmore by the way
just turned 25 years old the price is
wrong the price is wrong
[ __ ] i didn't don't forget to say that
oh i said it i went there
okay shout out to my good friend adam
sandler long distance cousin of mine
um happy gilmore that was a classic
and then bob parker years old and then
bob barker rest in peace
beat the living crap out of happy
gilmore he just did the he just did his
swing again
he did his infamous swing we saw that
and then shooter mcgavin
shooter uh came in and gave a little uh
uh throwback to the scene but um where
were we going with that sorry bob barker
price is wrong
uh paul weighed in no so yeah so long
story short i trust apple more simply
because they're not relying on the data
to make money
i see what you're saying we are exposing
the truth here guys mario's crunching
numbers what are your thoughts here you
teaming up
with facebook i i learned yesterday that
i got a lot of
app uh things going on in the background
yeah what was the one thing that now
we're going to talk about the fjords
thing
we talked about fjords yesterday my
buddy sbj
um we talked about oh you're from norway
i want to go to norway and see the
fjords
and two minutes later we get off the
phone he's getting uh ads
on facebook for fjords fjords are like
norwegian rivers yes
they're about their valleys and fjords
peaks and valleys exactly peaks
such as life which is very light and so
facebook was creeping on the come up in
the background
yep that's what yeah i i'm on team apple
here bro all right i've been on tba
team apple since i switched from my
blackberry in like 2010. there you go
when did you get uh
your first item about that time yeah i
do kind of miss the blackberry though
you could do some things like that what
could you do i don't remember what you
could do
you had a bigger keyboard i mean if
you're like writing and things like that
um it had a thing for each letter a key
for each letter but i
i think they should bring back the flip
phone i mean i think i would buy a flip
phone if they brought it back i would
have that as an alternate
i just unlocked for a nostalgia
breakfast i think it's more dramatic
when you're done you just like make that
noise
i'm done with you click now you're just
like a razor motorola
released a razor well eric obviously
still has a as a flip phone
well he just had that before he went
over to iphone congratulations
on living in the uh modern era 2020.
yeah paul who's your mic buddy yeah
there's one other story
uh that i want to bring up but remember
in i think it was like san bernardino
in california there was a a a terrorist
yes
a domestic terrorist guy and full of
years ago yeah 2015.
and um they wanted to go after uh the
the the police
department wanted to go after fbi wanted
his uh phone data
and apple said no that's part of our
user agreement we don't we're not
allowed to give out private information
wow so that's a huge to me a huge
example of them being pro
uh consumer right i think they're even
on a terrorist attack that's no there's
more to the story well i think you have
to get an affidavit you have to go
through the court system essentially
fbi wanted to to create for them to hack
and essentially create a back door to
access the phone without having to wait
for the court data and stuff like that
because they were saying there would be
a second there was possibilities of
being a second attack
apple then said that uh if they created
an opening or a back door
into it that could be then transferred
on other phones which would
decrease the privacy and security of the
access to
privacy is a real thing that's what
we're saying guys privacy is a real
thing
and you can choose to yeah allow it or
not allow it on your
phone yes and just you gotta give cook a
lot of credit because
that's leadership when you think about
it because it would be you know it's
almost like
you'd want to give that to the
authorities especially i mean that was
brutal that happened in december of 2015
and they go into these office buildings
and they shot all these employees it was
horrible um and you would think yes if
this could stop a future one it takes a
lot of guts to say no
you know the bigger picture here is more
important
respect i mean it says right here
facebook and apple's visions are
diverging and increasingly incompatible
incompatible what does that mean what
does that mean exactly is facebook not
going to be on the iphone
no it's just i mean it's going to be
there they're going opposite directions
yeah they are
opposite directions okay um let's go to
the next story
um big news today big news today we know
it's
on capitol hill there's a lot going on
today we will talk about i'll give you
the uh
the the lead into this and then we'll
kind of give uh some stories with this
so robin hood's ceo his name is vlad
tenev
he's reportedly staying at a hotel right
now instead of going home after
receiving
death threats that's pretty serious um
so robin hood ceo of latent is staying
at a hotel because of the backlash
following
the gamestop trading rally in late
january was a couple weeks ago robin
hood restricted trading
of gamestop shares on january 28th
following a 2
000 surge in the share price driven by
retail investors robin hood users
including members of wall street's wall
street bets forum on reddit
who cheered gamestop's rally accused the
firm of
unfairly manipulating free market
trading
some of the backlash was violent tenev
received
death threats and has avoided going home
in the past few days
the police in menlo park california
which is basically just outside silicon
valley
they were told last week that a handful
of protesters had thrown
dog feces which is dog [ __ ] on at robin
hood's
headquarters and saw through a statue on
the property so people are running up
on robin hood's headquarters taneb is
set to testify in a congressional
hearing on thursday which is
today it could be happening any second
about the firm's decision
decision to restrict trading and let me
give you a little more insight here you
know i printed out this article right
here
so here are some of the players that are
going to be testifying uh on capitol
hill today
so the leaders of robin hood vlad melvin
capital which is a hedge fund read it
because we just talked about reddit uh
you know they received three billion
dollars of new funding
citadel they were all testify as well as
uh this is sort of like a reddit trading
star roaring kitty
all about last month's game uh gamestop
trading turmoil
um here's a couple quotes and then i'm
going to get it over to you guys so we
think congressional hearing will focus
on understanding exactly what
occurred during the week of service
disruptions making sure that all
activity was appropriate and also
determining how to avoid a similar event
in the future
the prevailing narrative was that a band
of reddit inspired
small traders rose up against wall
street
by buying gamestop forcing a short
squeeze by professional hedge fund
managers
who were forced to cover their negative
bets or risk
catastrophic losses losses
robinhood which is a millennial favored
stock trading uh
they made the unpopular decision to
restrict trading of certain securities
obviously gamestop being one and then
tenef there's what he had to say i want
to be clear
any allegation that robin hood acted to
help hedge funds or any other special
interest to the detriment
of our customers is absolutely false
and marketing distorting rhetoric that's
the word from vlad tenev
um a lot of drama going on this is going
on on
on capitol hill today tom i know you got
some strong feelings on this well we'll
we'll see the heat's going to be on him
um i don't believe that quote what he
just said i think the hedge funds were
protected clearly
there is real anger i mean there are
some really really ticked off people
david portnoy is
you know the founder of barstool i mean
he wants him out um
calling for his head yeah you know he's
one of the he he founded this thing he's
a co-founder
of robin hood and and you know yeah and
it was you know it's a popular i mean a
highly thought of app until a few weeks
ago and now it's gone all gone in the
toilet i think his days are numbered i
think they got to get him out i mean
oh you think he's done well how does he
stay that's what i say because
as a ceo you want to you know exude some
strength and some confidence and some
you know you know project that you know
what you're doing and that you can
control a crisis and
that just hasn't happened i don't think
it's a great look when you say you're
hiding out in hotels and you're the ceo
now
i've never had death threats so i don't
know what i would do so i'm not going to
try to act like i'm in his shoes
but you know though death threats get
thrown out there a lot um there's a
difference between a death threat where
you're in true danger and someone's
going to come to your house and kill you
or someone posting something really
stupid on social media does that count
as a death threat
i mean it does it does i know in the in
the definition but is it
how legit is it i i don't know you're
saying there's different levels well
kind of
um i i would bro we should rip his head
off
it's better to be safe than sorry true
but then how about saying something like
this
i've got around the clock security
around me because i'm still working and
i'm trying to fix this mess
for the people that feel like they you
know that that weren't handled
that was handled fairly and this is a
quote from from our friend vlad
and then we'll flip it over to kai he
says as soon as the emails went out
talking about what happened with uh
robin hood the conspiracy theory started
coming so my
phone was blowing up how could you do
this how could you be
on the side of the hedge funds which he
says he's not taneb who is 33 years old
respect to at least you know
young dudes making things happen is
reportedly being coached
for the hearing by robin hood's chief
legal officer dan gallagher a former sec
commissioner
who also coached none other than mark
zuckerberg on his congressional hearing
right
right you need to be coached you can't
go in front of these guys without being
prepared
what's the quote guy
you know i think it'll be a fun thing to
watch today i think it'll be really
interesting i mean
you go into these saying is it going to
be a dog and pony show because a lot of
times
the senators like to huff and puff and
nothing gets done right they pull you in
front of congress
they have a congressional hearing they
act all tough but then nothing really
gets done this might be a little
different today
it'll be interesting to see how he
handles the bright lights of this type
of scrutiny
and you know i'll say this about the guy
i know nothing really about him okay i
just kind of evaluate
by you know what he's doing since this
crisis started and i don't think it's
been stellar
number one but he probably got into this
business with good intentions if you
name your company robin hood
right so you know it's not like he's
when you set something up like that it's
almost like you're not
in in favor from the right to the poor
but the hedge funds know what they're
doing on all these transactions
they're gonna and they're gonna
manipulate this thing to their advantage
so
it'll be interesting he's been under the
radar and under the you know the public
profile for so long but today it's the
opposite of that and
he could get exposed or he could come
across as someone that can say the
dude's in a hard place and
we talked about this a couple weeks ago
and i used the quote uh from what's the
song uh from reservoir dogs well a
little green bag and he's like
clowns to the left of me joker's to the
right here i am stuck in the middle with
you he's getting his
funding from big uh wall street firms
hedge funds you know investment firms
like that
but his customers are the millennial
retail traders like the guys on reddit's
uh who are so i mean you're you're
really in a hard place right there so he
has to
obviously appeal to where he's getting
his money clearly because he can't like
just say oh f you guys because then
maybe the business gets
screwed but he obviously can't screw
over his actual customer base
he's in a tough spot but uh kai what are
your thoughts on this
no i think uh if you think of it and
again this is reportedly staying at a
hotel so it's not confirmed that he's
staying at the
marriott resort whatever whatever uh so
for all we know this could be
fake news like we know there's more than
you don't think he's
no we who knows i think he's like faking
that he's staying at a hotel
reportedly draw sympathy who knows this
might be something the old reporter
howard
this might seem like he's a coward uh
however
i'd think he's staying at a hotel bro i
mean who i mean if
he probably has security still i i i
don't buy the hotel thing
you don't think okay look i stay in a
lot of hotels i don't want vlad next to
me
and the people trying to kill him okay
out right now yeah i think it's more
dangerous if you go to a hotel you're
putting everybody else in jeopardy yeah
vlad stay away from my hotels
um however i do i do think that uh
tom has a point uh that um
the people that are the traders like the
day traders and a lot of these people
that joined the wall street bets i see
them as the people that are gamers
they're the t people that are kind of
like trolls where they're they're
keyboard warriors like people call them
where they s they throw a lot of
board warriors warriors yeah exactly
where they throw a lot of comments
what's the famous drake quote he goes
trigger fingers turned to twitter
fingers yeah something like that
no it's that perfect it's that used to
you know back in the day you'd roll up
on somebody whatever
yeah now i don't like you i'm the
toughest guy on youtube
i'll show you what's going on buddy oh
he's a soy boy yeah so
yeah we had to go there so uh so i think
a lot of these people that are
just accusations now however you got to
take them serious to an extent of
of making sure you're protected and
you're taking proper precautions
um but i do also think that this this is
this will fade
uh it's a storm and it's obviously
weathering up this too shall pass this
is too shocking well here you brought up
the
you know the gamification of this um
here's some of the uh here's a quote by
representative james comer from
kentucky's a republican he told cnbc
he's been proud to see a company like
robin hood emerge leveling the play
field for retail investors so he's sort
of on the side of robin hood he says
however cromer
here's a quote so robin hood may be a
glorification
of the gamification of investments if
you want an exciting video interface
you should go to gamestop and buy video
game
don't go to robin hood to buy gamestop
is that essentially what you're saying
here is that it's just
they're you want to play video games go
play video games kai is a great video
gamer
but if you want to trade trading um no
i'd say investing is supposed to be
boring
it's essentially what he's trying to say
i'm not i don't necessarily that's not
what i'm pointing to
what i'm pointing at is the people that
are doing this and that are part of the
wall street bets and the part of all
this movement of let's short gamestop or
let's increase game stop
i think these are the type of people
that would also be
more in that in the pro prone to play be
playing video games
or talking trash over the internet or
just plus they're in forums where where
you can get it yeah
exactly so i want to know from our
audience are you guys on the side
of robin hood are you are you guys doing
anything with robinhood are you
investing
is um you know where where you at with
this are you pro vad
vlad i just i love the comment section
over here kai would you mind would you
manage that
what's so funny hey
you know am i getting crushed over here
you know you know it's go you got some
supporters
you have some some some hate uh you know
it's it's
trigger fingers turn to twitter fingers
buddy this is what this is what it is
what we're doing is
a bunch of keyboard warriors in this
chat keyboard warriors and we love it if
they're not talking about you you're not
doing something right
the the first time i heard about this
yeah you know because this did
this was so big a few weeks ago it was
just crazy i re there's a convenience
store where i live and i and i would go
in there and the guy that works there
would go
i don't know why he decided to tell me
this but hey man hey i
i bought some amc stock and i'm going
god you know that's really
that's interesting and and that's all i
thought it was just randomly told
i'm going man that's that's really cool
that you did that i mean that you found
the time i i find it a little bit odd
this is before i knew anything about
what was going on i found it a little
bit odd you know with movie theaters
being down but maybe he's thinking that
they're going to come back or he's got
some information
and then the next day i'd go in there
and he told me about more stock and this
and that
and then i talked to him i saw him on
sunday i said hey man i was trying to
reach you i wanted to find out how how
things went for you what did you do he
goes
he bought it at six it was as low as six
right amc
i think he got he said he made thirty
thousand
thirty thousand bucks doing this thing
wow he's kept it in there
he hasn't been able to get it out yet or
he's chosen not to maybe he's gonna like
keep it in there and
move on amc specifically yeah well i
think he may have had some game stop too
but
mario would you pull up game stop stock
let's see what this has to say because
game stop lost like 90 percent
my point is value my point is he's not
the guy you would expect to be some guy
that would be
making a small fortune you know
investigating this guys that works at
the gas station
well at a convenience store and here he
had that opportunity through robin hood
it's the type of person it caters to but
he got his information from reddit
i mean they were getting their marching
orders and they just said but i mean
clearly yeah i got asked about but
that's how they all did it you know
that's where the forum was it's
collective it's
it's collective and and i think that
that is what tom saying that it's not
these typical people that
would and then obviously a situation
like this there's a
there isn't a realistic return that this
happens all the time like this is a
the frustrating thing is if you had if
you know you made money and they want to
like get it out
right i mean yeah and that that's where
the real anger is they would stop the
change they would only let you
sell they wouldn't let you buy is that
what was that was going on yeah
there was a period on robin hood where
they shut down buying and they would
only let you sell
now robin hood claims that that's
because they they needed enough cash on
reserve
because from my understanding how it
works is that they there's a there's a
time when robin hood when you buy the
the app on robin hood
is obviously just kind of the interface
and then on the back end they then buy
it from somebody else that that kind of
does it on the
back end so they were saying that they
didn't have enough money to support
the trades that were being bought and so
or bought
and that's why they had to do another
round of funding to get in more money so
they'd be able to pull
have the pool to cover their costs the
funny the funny part of the story is
watching
those hedge fund managers who everybody
thought was so smart get
killed yeah and i think and obviously
and obviously i see that a lot of the
people were
saying main street versus wall street
and that main street won
and stuff like that and i agree and for
hedge funds now obviously they're trying
to claim that this was all
bad and they're going after the main
street people but
in a sense they lost like they they just
need to take the l and stop crying the
biggest winners
yeah were the hedge funds that bailed
out the other hedge funds steve cohen
the new owner of the mets yep
he he came to the rescue of a couple of
them and you could you imagine the terms
on those
that's like do you think he was the
money probably oh yeah yeah to to bail
him out in a matter of days and pump a
couple billion
into their account so they don't get
destroyed or good point let's talk about
this gamestop
stock you go up max yeah go max mario
yeah i mean look look at that surgery
even even there if you look at it it's
now at 45.
go uh before the peak see where it was
at before the peak just
six months mario yeah you're looking at
six months
and that's good you're still looking at
what it go it went from 45
to and before that it was at what five
ten
yeah so that's a forex return since the
beginning of january
i'd love to see how many senators made
money on this i bet they did i bet
there's a few
well speaking of senators let's talk
about what you know she's not in the
news a lot these days but she's going to
go get take her mantle today
senator elizabeth warren of
massachusetts a long-standing critic of
wall street is calling for a
ban on a forced arbitration which
essentially
prevents consumers from going to court
if they are wrong by a company or
product because
they agreed to the terms of service
interesting she's not sort of defending
the retail
traders out there here's what she said
robin hood promised to democratize
trading
but hid information about its
prerogative to change the rules by
cutting off trades without notice
and about cons customers inability to
access the courts
if they believe they've been cheated
behind dozens of pages of legalese
warren said in a statement what is not
clear from robin hood's response to my
questions
is the full extent of robin hood's ties
here it is kai
to giant hedge funds and market makers
i'm going to keep pushing regulators
to use the full range of their
regulatory tools to ensure the fair
operation of our market particularly for
small investors so she is on the side of
the small investors because that
initial sentence threw me off were yeah
with this guy
i was confused what you were reading
yeah i say next story yeah
we're moving on to the next story she's
anti-capitalism we should ignore
everything she said so we're not on the
fan we're not on the side
so here's what we're doing there you go
nice try elizabeth warren
you're out okay you know who we're
missing right now
you know who we're missing right now
yeah can you hear that before
shout out to patrick bet david can we
give you a point we'll be waiting tell
your point we've been waiting
let's move on to the next topic um
this is something that that i believe
you were very interested in talking more
about
um and here it is let's talk about bill
gates and what's going on with him he
says
i believe he's on page eight he says
bill gates
rich nation should move to 100 synthetic
beef bill gates recently said that he
believes rich nations
should would help the global fight
against climate change
by consuming only plant-based 100
synthetic meat products instead of beef
you can get used to the taste difference
and the claim is they're going to make
it taste even better over time
says gates the philanthropist and
microsoft
co-founder said that he is hopeful that
a turn to plant-based proteins will
combat
methane emissions produced by livestock
even gates recognize that this idea is
hard to swallow
saying that people you can't have cows
anymore
saying to people you can't have cows
anymore talk about
talk about a politically unpopular
approach to things however the global
hunger for plant-based foods continues
to grow here are some numbers for you
morningstar forecast that the
plant-based meat market will reach
74 billion by 2029
the end of the decade up from currently
12 billion
that was in 2019 and beyond meat is
working with mcdonald's and fast food
chains like taco bell and kfc
to roll out plant-based sandwiches and
other alternative meat items
this year is that the end of this story
kai yep
okay this is some this is i mean is this
a hundred percent that's what he's
saying what do you think about it here's
what i think about it bill gates needs a
side hustle
he needs something else to do other than
come up with these wild stupid things
that he does
three times a week uh he's too bored
uh you know he's got his side 100 he's
got he's he's he's been talking about
vaccines well then hustle more on that
and
and keep beef out of it okay warren
buffett is good friends
with bill gates right i think they're
the best of friends do you know that
there's
seven million cows in nebraska and
there's 1.8 million
people in nebraska do you know how big
the beef industry is
in nebraska in this country i mean
you want i mean for him to throw
something out that i mean it's almost
like
i think it does bill gates legacy a
little hard because he almost comes
across as a crackpot now there might be
some
scientific thing that he could spin and
and you know in
387 years down the road if we did this
it would benefit
but no one's gonna buy this right now or
or have you ever tried fake beef
i've had a beyonce have i and they're
okay i mean it takes like a bad turkey
burger if you ask me
you know beyond meat it's okay i mean i
think they're gonna be improving it
constantly
but how can you make a statement like
this when when that
industry is so big it affects so many
jobs and so many livelihoods
maybe it just seems like when i see a
bill gates headline now i'm going
how crazy can i think that just when you
see a bill gates headline is it like
instant non-credibility at this point
i don't know bill gates is you know who
he is so you know his accomplishments
speak for themselves but
how are you going to get america to go
100 fake beef that
will not happen you will have a lot of
americans moving to poor countries
okay because he's saying all rich
countries should get rid of beef and
just have fake beef well a lot of
americans would be leaving this country
well i mean listen according to the
numbers here we go right morning star
forecast that the plant-based meat
market will reach 74 billion by 2029 up
from currently
12 billion that was last year i say
that's a small number i'd say 74 will be
higher than that it's it's big and
they're going to improve it every single
year
it's going to get better and better and
better but i just i just don't think
we're there yet where americans can wrap
their arms
i think the problem that we're having
right now is the fact that i mean this
is why we're talking about
because if he said rich nation should
move to 40
synthetic beef we would we wouldn't even
be questioning this we'd be like all
right cool like
have more you know synthetic beef
whatever the health
synthetic beef is you know fake meat or
whatever um
but the fact that he's saying a hundred
percent again headlines
is that the people like what do you mean
i can't have a freaking hamburger
eric glover every day for lunch he has a
hamburger every day
it's crazy we know what your number one
uh thing that you like to eat is but
um burgers is at the top of the list
yeah i went there
now uh would you eat fake meat
absolutely absolutely not you would not
no that's my point you're gonna get a
lot you just wouldn't if we said 100
fake beef you're not even gonna have a
bite of that no i want my meat no
and there's two i want my meat steak
people there's too many people like that
so yeah i mean you go to texas right now
you're gonna tell some dude in texas
driving around in his truck hanging out
in the
it'll be like i can't have a hamburger
it'll be like prohibition it'll be a
huge underground black market for
damn the underground beef market
or the mafia is going to get involved
and it's going to become a bigger
business
than it is now because it's going to go
underground i mean there's there's
history has shown time time again that's
how it works guys give me something
different give me a different
perspective i know you love hamburgers
you're from norway though so there's
something
what do you got here's a prediction oh
what you got we have the
the gasoline industry or the gas for car
gas cars versus electrical vehicles yes
i think
in the future you're gonna see a push
towards you know how we're pushing
towards electrical vehicles it's gonna
be a push
towards more plant-based beef
and a lower decrease on beef i don't
think it's going to go
a hundred percent overnight that's not
yeah we have air glares in the world
a lot of them what's this what's his
point on the point the point on the
admissions is essentially if you're
pla if you're um if you're planting
right so
to create a cow you need you need uh you
need a lot of acres for food
and they need to eat and 90 essentially
if you think of it roughly 90 of the
food that a cow eats goes to just
maintenance right 10 percent goes to
growth so if you
they need to eat a lot of food in order
to gain
a lot of weight right so say they're 100
pounds then they need a thousand pounds
of food which that food could be better
used if you go if you go
directly to grain and or they create
fake fake beef out of it
so there's a lot of inefficiencies with
beet and raising
animals because they need to eat a lot
just to maintain
or to grow and get bigger so that's
where he's saying the
admission comes out that it's more
pollution for sustaining animals
than to let just eat the grass or the
the plant base that you could
be planting on the same area let me pick
up where you where you went by the way
well done you're going predictions
i mean he's drawing diagrams venn
diagrams that makes sense good job yeah
so so that's that's his argument that
we're he's saying that we're
a first world nation that we can afford
that and we can
um make more use out of the land that
we're on
so that's kind of where he's going with
the admissions of the methane that
cows produce and then also just the
general stuff around it now
how realistic is it to transition from
one to the other i don't know
but one thing i suggest is we do a blind
meat test where we have
to put down our idea and we see an
episode there can we get can we put that
on an idea
yeah a a a taste a taste test yeah
i i want to see
not here able to spot the difference
between i would say
and real meat i would love that i would
love to go beyond meat i would love to
you know be a connoisseur of beyond me
because the health benefits alone i
would yeah i would be ecstatic if i were
to
you know the nba players have really
helped push beyond me they're based in
el segundo
which is the next city over from where i
live and they really they really are
blown up could you imagine if elon musk
had come out and said we should be 100
fake beef could you measure that would
have done to the stock yes
yeah but you know what i just it's
unfair to pick on one industry when you
have as much influence as you do as bill
gates and i
and if i was in that industry where i
could be really truly harmed
i would be really resentful for him to
say something like that i think it would
be more responsible to say hey look
the benefits outweigh you know having
this much beef consumption and here's
why let me tell you
you know this country is capable of
maybe getting there i think it'll be
it'll prolong life it'll
cut down cardiovascular disease and
heart disease but he comes out with this
100 and that just scares everybody
and it completely dilutes his point and
now you're not going to believe him
you're not you're going to be anti-this
whatever he says about it i think he's
saying
i disagree with you and i'll tell you
why like i said if he said hey we
should eat more synthetic beef and
that's all he said and just kind of left
it just you know hey
do you do what you want we wouldn't even
be talking about this story right now
the fact that he
listen agree with bill gates or don't
agree with bill gates the guy
is a genius and he knows what he's doing
if he comes out there and says
rich nation should move to 100 synthetic
beef he knows that that's going to be a
headline
like you know thinking of headlines here
you write the headlines for vt post
you know that's clickbait materials
exactly what we're doing right now we're
talking about this
topic talking about your predictions
listen things were trending in a
different direction
in america and in the world for
everything but what i think happened is
the pandemic
you know mate exacerbated a million
different types of changes to say hold
on what's going on here
you talked about electric car vehicles
versus gasoline and oil power
you know clearly there's some green
changes going on with that
clearly this beef topic that we're
talking about right there i can't tell
you how many calls i'm getting from
people
bitcoin bitcoin bitcoin bitcoin so you
got the bitcoin you got the ethereum you
get the crypto like
you know clearly people are making a
move in that direction obviously
zoom you know you know you're not
traveling for meetings talking about
emissions and bill gates
says he's one of the you know flying
private planes and doing all that he
gives off more missions than anybody um
things have changed and i think
this is kind of to your prediction this
is something that we're gonna have you
ever even
thought about not eating a normal burger
less than five because someone said oh
you can have a veggie patty or a burger
five years ago it wasn't even a freaking
question i've now i'm like yeah it's
it's been proven you shouldn't eat more
red meat more than once a week right now
wink wink at ucla eating swallow
think about the first um cell phones
right and how far we've come with that
exactly
i think it can be the same thing talked
about blackberry and iphone something
like that exactly
have you ever had anybody tried the
sausage that beyond meat makes is that
any better i i
this guy eats it every day this guy eats
it literally
every day so recently paul what do you
eat every day for lunch soy riso it is
changed my life really it it because you
can't eat
regular chorizo every day you'll die but
ceriso
gives you that opportunity to have that
amazing chorizo flavor
uh but healthy interesting this podcast
is brought to you by
rito hey it gives you if you're gonna
eat uh regular chorizo you will die
and i really wanna like it i really do i
would love to fail that taste test
because i would be all in i really would
and i think they will have i mean you're
a cali boy this this must be like all
over the streets of l.a
yeah i mean you must have million
friends that are going vegan and doing
all that kind of stuff no
yeah but it's already happened right i
mean that's already just organically
kind of it's the only
panic yeah no one's making a big
announcement that hey i'm going this
already happened in california
bill last point on this from me bill
gates better hate steak
because if he's ever caught in a
steakhouse right now people are going to
take pictures of this hypocrite
and they're going to be sending it
everywhere so he better not eat a burger
in public when you come out with a
statement like this
is it me i i think
bill gates like i'm on the side if bill
gates says something
automatically i'm thinking bill gates
knows what he's doing
he knows what he's talking about i think
he like kind of you said like i don't
know he needs to kind of have a side
hustle or stick to his day job
i kind of think he's that smart and that
informed that he kind of knows what he's
talking about
my question to you is when you hear bill
gates say something do you have
like the oh he's a fake news kind of a
guy like i had that problem with trump
no doubt
if he said it i was like i don't know
here's my problem with him and
to your point here it's not that i doubt
his his brilliance i mean clearly the
guy's a genius
i just question his motives and that's
the one thing when i hear his agenda
if what he's saying does it benefit him
somehow down the road and
and whatever's happened with him in the
past has kind of created that for me
where that is more or less the first
thing i think of when he says that
is this benefiting him his foundation or
something more that
to the detriment of how it would affect
yeah maybe this is just me being naive
i'm sure that's a perfect segue to some
comments right there
but i don't think he does it for his
money or to improve his
like i just think he generally cares i
think the jury's out on that
to be honest jury's out do you trust
bill gates like just trust him as a
human being like trust his instincts
or do you think he's kind of like a
selfish looking out for himself like
where are you at with no
more stuff he could be doing if he
wanted to further his
hidden political agenda in that sense uh
i do the guy's been top five richest guy
in the world for the last 20 years i
think he is a believer of what he's
doing now obviously does everyone agree
most likely not uh but i do think that
he especially with kind of
with his views on climate change and the
things that need to be done in order to
reach the goals
um i think that he's kind of in tune
with those and
i can see where he's coming from you
trust bill gates instincts paul
um you trust bill gates i'm gonna say no
uh you do not trust me
if he says something right away i'm not
gonna just blindly incline only
because i've heard enough red flag
stories
okay in the last 10 years about him uh
that's my question
i'd love to hear the audience just trust
or mistrust them bill gates do you trust
him
or do you not trust him eric where you
at with this trust or mistrust i don't
trust him and
there's no like solid debt i can give
you yeah i just he gives me a vibe i
just can't trust him so the
the there's he doesn't have the trust
factor for you interesting mario do you
trust bill gates no so i
have an opinion on this i think that
sometimes like saying someone's name we
get a little emotional
right so as i'm listening i'm like man
everybody's so emotional about bill
gates
you're crying i'm not crying but i think
that when it comes to something like
this what i take out of it is
how anything extreme is always going to
rub us the wrong way
but if we are naive to believe that we
can't get there
then we're very naive everybody both
sides middle i don't care because
if you would have told me a few months
ago that everywhere you freaking go
you're going to put on a mask
even when you're walking in an office
and when you're going to the restroom
when you
yeah and then you feel guilty for not
wearing if you would have told me that
would have been society today yeah where
you look at a chick you look at a dude
you're looking at people you're looking
in business meetings and then you're
doing interviews recently right now i
was like i prefer to keep a mask on i'm
going to wear my mask
if you would have told that to me yeah
six months ago i would have said
hell no that's extreme 100 of people
won't do it
so when i hear 100 today here's what i
take from this
is we cannot be naive for me
anything at an extreme is too much
so yes i agree with you adam where if
you say if he would have said look we
can gradually increase
and start moving into a little bit more
plant-based that was my point by the way
right tom thank you and i agree with tom
not with adam i never agree with adam
unless it's about what we're gonna eat
so the other part is beef baby the other
part is
that i also trust the science if there
are facts that are leading and i just
looked up an article here while you guys
were talking but
science does say that methane emissions
are increasing so what the hell are we
doing about
it you know it's really good for me i'm
33 but what about
you know and i do think about what about
the youth what about society what about
the environment
like we're kind of effed up you know to
not care about those things
because we do need some longevity what
freaking planet are we going to live on
so i think that is important as well but
anytime we go extreme i think that's the
case
um but the other part i think regulation
is very important too
when we interviewed if you go back and
you watch if you haven't watched it
already go watch the interview with chad
sullivan
but talk you know he talks a direct
impact about the meat industry
go watch that interview and understand a
little bit more about the whole
aspect of being a business owner and
what they had to go through dealing with
covet and regulating where meat was
coming from at that point
because if you understand the world that
they're in you can't just put them out
of business either you have no idea who
you're affecting
so if regulation is included i mean me
could gradually get better if you
process it better because look if you're
going to pick right now and i'm reading
the comments but
are you going to go to burger king
you're going to go to mcdonald's you're
going to go to shake shack are you going
to go to in and out are you going to go
where are you going to go to a
restaurant like a down here
chop steak house and you're going to go
ask for a burger where do you get your
meat from
so i hate to go long-winded on this but
i think look if you're extreme about it
you're going to get a lot of hate if
you're naive about it don't forget what
happened with mass you're probably going
to put one on right after the podcast
wherever you go
and then from there we need to improve
regulation but we can't be emotional
when it comes to
an individual and their name or whatever
they did on their past
because if you're perfect then i mean
you should be the one commenting
and walking on water great great great
insight by the legendary
i'd also be curious to know how much of
because obviously if you have like
organically plant-raised meat which is
like the non-processed
the straight cows just coming right off
the farm that
healthy meat the the high quality meat
right
but then you also have all the like
crappy meat which is a lot of like the
mcdonald's meat and a lot of just ground
stuff and
the the stuff but paul used to eat
before he went to the store so
the the and and that percentage i'd be
curious of like how much
is the good quality meat and how much of
the meat out there is just kind of the
stuff that
they're force feeding the cows so that
they they get gain weight
there's a documentary there as soon as
possible because that meat can't be too
healthy either and that's where i think
that a lot of that could be moved
more towards a plant-based meat and that
would also help environment i think
i think the point is things have changed
right things have changed whether it's
electric vehicles whether it's bitcoin
whether it's
um synthetic meat we're open to new
things now to say no and we're never
doing i'm never doing this
like our friend galera said i would
never like maybe you're going to
consider that now i don't know
if we do the taste i look forward to
this taste test yes
okay that's what and just last point
about bill gates this is why i kind of
find
the instant credit i won't say instant
credibility this is why i trust him
pull up something called the billionaire
pledge pull up something called a
billion are you guys familiar with this
is billionaire pledge you know about
this
okay basically this is what he started
with what the gates found bill and
melinda gates foundation
he's basically saying listen guys we've
had the luxury of living in america here
making billions right he's a capitalist
right he's a democrat a capitalist you
can be both
um wait wait wait should i agree to the
privacy notice here or no
let me know if i should agree or not
agree i'm not sure anymore this is about
building this is about building on a
wonderful tradition of philanthropy stop
mario
that will ultimately help the world
become a much better place that is the
number one quote
on that on that on his site um to me
if you're a billionaire and you're
basically saying i think what's the
number they're going to pledge
90 50 is it more than 50. i think he's i
think some of these people are pledging
90 percent of their wealth if you're
worth a hundred
billion dollars and you give you know 90
billion dollars to
charity of your choice um that's pretty
impressive man that to me
gets you some instant credibility no but
you don't trust bill gates
anyway if you if you want to check that
out uh uh
billionaire pledge bill gates the giving
pledge that's what it's called
the giving place it certainly puts
pressure on other billionaires doesn't
it 100 percent
off the top hey zuck did you do it yeah
i did hey uh musk did you do it yeah
a lot of them uh that or i mean
obviously there's some of them that just
put it into a trust for their kids and
their kids kids yeah yeah
all that good stuff but a lot of them
also have other foundations like
i know there's a norwegian billionaire
um a hotel tycoon that was approached
and he said no
because he had already a different uh
charity he was doing himself that he was
giving to
where he was but at least he has that
chair yeah yeah i don't know he was
playing i mean how many majority
do you need how many homes do you need
if you can actually help the world to me
that's where i mean bill gates listen
there he could be i'm not saying he's
the type of this person if you've got
what 80 billion dollars what's his net
worth right now something ridiculous
yeah i mean i'm guessing something never
know it's 130 or is he in the 100
million 100 billion
range he's number five in the world
right now so it's somewhere near 100
billion all right cool
133 billion 133 billion do you know how
many planes and
boats and yachts and but he's just like
look i just want to help the world i
like what he's doing
i like what he's doing with clean water
and sanitation in in the third world
countries
he's saving lives so i respect him for
that but he also didn't build a
non-profit right so this guy has
motives that are self-serving as well so
he just i think you just got to be
cautious with his messaging
but he's also revolution uh giving money
or philanthropy pretty much the most
since
you have a rockefeller or those people
as well so he's obviously changed it and
given it the business
um aspect of making it as efficient as
possible i got respect for bill gates
all right let's get to the next topic
this was uh
joe biden your friend our friend friend
of the show he might call in later
um he did a town hall the other day
and uh someone stood up and asked him
would you cancel
fifty thousand dollars in student loan
debt what was the quote that he said
kai he said i will not make that happen
he stood his ground
here's the story president joe biden
shot down a proposal to cancel fifty
thousand dollars in student loan debt
for every borrower despite the pressure
from leading democratic lawmakers
to do that obviously that's the bernies
of the world the aocs the elizabeth
warrens
an audience member at a cnn town hall
told byden that student debt is quote
unquote
crushing her friends family and fellow
americans
we need student loan forgiveness beyond
the potential
ten thousand dollars your administration
has proposed she said
we need at least 50 grand minimum
will you be able to make that happen by
and responded i will not make that
happen
one sentence biden has proposed
cancelling ten thousand dollars in
student
loan debt as a part of the coronavirus
relief while democratic senators chuck
schumer and elizabeth warren
called on buying to cancel up to 50
grand in student loan debt
per bower borrower during tuesday's town
hall a couple days ago by and expressed
skepticism
about the idea of canceling the billions
of dollars of debt that people
who have gone to harvard yale and penn
referring to ivy league
institutions is that going to be
forgiven rather than the use
then use that money to provide for early
education for young children
who come across disadvantaged
circumstances biden said
so a lot of the concern with biden
was he he was going to go extreme he was
going to pander to the aocs of the world
he was going to cave he's a puppet he's
not going to you know stand his ground
he's spineless all this sleepy joe
and he's like no i'm not going 50 grand
sorry
i'm not gonna do it i'm i might give you
ten i might
but i'm not going 50. line in the sand
i'm not going to do it obviously the you
know the story
two weeks ago was aoc says no we need to
push them
we can't just settle for 10 grand we
need to push we need to push
seems like he's made up his mind do you
believe him tom you know i do
i will say this i'm mad enough to say
that i underestimated him a little bit
and i'm impressed i'm impressed by his
actions here i'll judge him
on a per case basis but for this i think
it i think it takes strength
to flat out say to someone asking you
that question because the politician
always wants to
validate them make them feel good yes
i'll do whatever yes it's
it's complete bs i think it takes
strength to walk around he could say i'm
thinking about it i'm loving we're
considering
i came out and said no yeah not gonna
happen and i i applaud him for that and
a couple things number one i i was
i guess my biggest fear was that he
would be that puppet and he's showing so
far
that he's not he they they've they've
completely minimized the squad
and these radicals i mean these far left
he he's basically saying i got no time
for you
here's my theory on this joe biden is
old school
he was a senator for 40 years all right
he's paid his dues he's not going to
finally get in the big chair
and let these young punks who don't know
what they're talking about who run on
pure emotion
who don't bring any of the real concepts
of what america
what made america great into their
arguments i love the fact he's
heismanning
all of them still giving him the stiff
arm great analogy right there but you
know he doesn't even listen to him which
is even better
and imagine what that's doing to them
it's minimizing them completely
and and now they're just sounding like
you know with crazy these young punks
yeah
and you know speaking of young punks kai
how you doing over there buddy student
loan debt what are your thoughts on this
no i think uh i mean the first thing
that comes to my mind is why are we
letting universities off the hook
okay well go deeper on that go ahead and
have the no exactly but yeah but the
kids have the debt i mean they knew what
they're
that what they're going into you don't
look it's not like they're all hidden
costs i mean you see very clearly
i remember when i was looking at schools
i saw very clearly like tuition
semester xyz and you're like all right
you're doing two semesters a year times
four years
and you can crunch the numbers pretty
quickly um so i think if anything if
we're trying to
limit limit student debt you should go
after the universities that are hiking
up these
educations where you're paying i don't
know 20 30 grand a semester for a
zoom college i don't i don't see that
like well
i mean look at the what does harvard
have in their uh
in their harvard fund what is it called
the endowment and they're endowment
hundreds of billions and billions of
dollars where they could pay for every
harvard student the next
probably tens of years and somehow they
still need that money just laying around
there
and they're charging full price even
though nobody's on school
at school so i mean i think that's what
i think is outrageous that
we're accepting that there can just
charge these astronomical fees without
even thinking
oh and then the question is well we need
to forgive the student debt from the
from the from the people the students
coming there but it's like no
first of all you know what you're
getting into second of all why aren't we
turning the the lens of focusing on the
schools why the hell are you
uh charging this tuition like what are
they actually getting for this tuition
and
why is it so high and i think those are
the two bigger questions rather than
looking at what you're going to do
another interesting study which was done
by university
of a working chicag published monday by
the university of chicago
becker friedman institute for economics
show that
erasing all student debt would distribu
uh
would distribute 192 billion
to the top 20 earners in the us
but just 29 billion to the bottom 20
percent of us say those numbers one more
time please
um if they're gonna if they're by
forgiving the love
student that uh they would 190
billion would go to the top 20 percent
top 20 earners in the u.s
and just 29 would go to the bottom
20 percent so the rich would get richer
well the rich would would get
less they would get more debt uh race
because they have bigger loans
of course you're going to harvard you're
going to go and the percentage of them
are more interesting
grad school exactly so here's the
question guys because i want to i want
to cover a couple of topics what's the
number
is it 10 it's clearly not 50 is it zero
what number are you comfortable with
erasing why is he doing it at all i mean
uh
zero no no bailout whatsoever where does
it okay
thank god he said no to wiping it all
away because there'd be no such thing as
debt agree more
agree what about car loans what about
mortgages what about credit card debt
everybody would be up incredibly
slippery slopes so
look i don't think you want to that's
not his job is to
to finally become president and then
just figure out what debt loads he can
wipe away
so i would say well especially when
you're adding more stimulus 1.9
proposals
imagine just the the truth what's that
what's the current student loan debt 1.5
trillion marrow you want to make 1.8
1.8 is it that high now how do you even
manage this
you know as far as wiping away this
these loans and the percentages and
it would be an absolute nightmare so
kudos to him
mario aguilar what's the number 1.7
1.7 kai you've been like one point off
on every like bob barker would be very
upset with you right now you're like one
you're
you're a little over on everything this
is what it is paul's car so what you got
kyle would be going to the showcase
showdown for us
i think i had a point uh but i want to
go further on kai's point i
i think again they're trying to solve
maybe the student loan debt
but really there is an opportunity for
the country to make more money
and we all are our free market
capitalist here
um but they should change the tax
bracket of universities instead of
you can charge whatever you want cool
but now you're paying taxes they
they've been you know protected by the
government
and don't pay taxes but they can charge
whatever you want well
there's a little bit of a a math problem
wrong there so
i think reversing that would actually
solve more problems you'd
increase the revenue of our country and
be able to afford it and then people can
pick and choose whether they want to go
there
and again give them more of that plus
they could use they could earmark some
of that tax money to take care of
ten thousand dollars or ten percent of
this debt you can actually pay for their
own problems
a big part of it as well is like you
have i i get that
schools if you're just thinking like
class and this and the other that
they're that they're not taxed but you
have schools
that have major football teams you have
major baseball teams
all these other sports teams where
they're mostly major football and
basketball
yeah where they have arenas that are
housing like thousands of
people where they're charging for the
tickets they're charging for sales of
jerseys or
what have you food anything like that
and on top of that they have major tv
contracts and all of this
they're funneling money in and and
they're still not taxed
that doesn't make sense either so bottom
line we agree with biden on this
we thumbs up or thumbs down on biden's
decision to stand his ground
you said thumbs up yes stand his ground
hundred percent yeah thumbs up on this
bonus thumbs up positive in his book
look joe biden getting thumbs up i love
paul's idea though
seriously my daughter just graduated
from college last year and she got
completely robbed
because she wasn't able to experience
the final months she she couldn't even
have a graduation
yeah they should cut a check and pay
some of the money back to the parents
that's not what we signed up for that's
not you know what i mean especially a
school like she went to pepperdine
where the graduation is on a cliff
overlooking the ocean it's an incredible
experience
and she got robbed probably the only
pepperdine class that wasn't able to do
it
yeah college is man it it's changing
if you watch what's going on it is
changing it needs to
affect the actual universities though
because it's starting to affect the big
college football programs
they're giving the football players more
leeway you know it used to be total
control by these coaches they make five
million dollars and they're just
dictators
now if you if you're not happy where you
are you can enter this transfer portal
so you can essentially just leave if
you're a college football player college
coaches are freaking out
i think the same thing will happen with
chancellors if they start
saying hey look you know we're going to
take a good look at this gravy train
that you've created for yourself here
creating all your own rules you're
responsible for educating these kids
which
a lot of people aren't in favor of your
your methods right now
i would love for them to take a big big
look at it because there's a lot of
money there
that could be going in other directions
great word gravy train i like that word
um all right staying on politics we just
covered biden
and his town hall let's talk about trump
versus mcconnell
the the the fight we've all been waiting
on
donald trump rips mitch mcconnell as he
seeks to exert leadership
after the impeachment trial donald trump
attacked senate minority leader that's a
new title for him
minority leader mitch mcconnell the
gop's highest-ranking elected official
after comments he made about trump's
culpability for the insurrection
at the u.s capitol on january 6. the
republican party
can never be respected or strong with
political leaders like senator mitch
mcconnell at its helm
did you hear that quote right there the
republic the republican party
can never again be respected or strong
with political leaders like mcconnell i
mean this is
gloves are off they are talking trash
the statement came
three days after mcconnell criticized
trump over the attack on the capital
although he voted to acquit him at the
impeachment trial
mcconnell said he did so because he did
not think it was constitutional to hold
an impeachment trial for a former
president the senate republican leader
held trump responsible for the attack
saying his false claims of fraud in the
election he lost to joe biden
inspired extremist followers to commit
violence to insurrection as he's talking
about
quote unquote from mcconnell this was an
intensifying
crescendo of conspiracy theories
orchestrated by an outgoing president
who seemed determined
to either overturn the voters decisions
or else
torch our institutions on the way out
this is mcconnell versus trump
here's what this is amazing what you
have here is mcconnell who believes in
institutions i mean mcconnell he looks
like a turtle he's kind of you know
you know you can say go go on but one
thing he does respect
is the rule of law and institutions and
he's basically called out trump
saying you don't respect either of that
you don't respect the people you don't
respect institutions
came out and just ripped in to did you
see the speech
mcconnell yeah mcconnell speech he
ripped into trump but then obviously in
typical mcconnell
fashion voted not to impeach him you
know because you can't
impeach a um non-sitting president
non-sitting president
so then trump basically came out and he
said listen
with leaders like this guy the
republican party ain't going nowhere so
whose side you got
you got trump's side you're on
mcconnell's side you got to pick a side
well with trump you get the highlights
you get the bluster so here
he called him he called mcconnell a
dower
sullen an unsmiling political hack i
mean that's good writing i got to give
him credit for that i mean he didn't
say those words those are the examples
no no i'm saying he didn't come up with
those words so maybe he did i'm not sure
what was the quote he called mcconnell a
dour sullen
an unsmiling politician we've heard
we've heard donald trump speak
okay
donald trump isn't just doing this for
you know to
get his name out there there's more to
this and one of his
problems with mcconnell is his wife
elaine chao
right who served in the cabinet as the
uh transportation
secretary so he felt because of the
influence of his wife on mcconnell
that he's they're incapable of being
tough on china and that was
basically the crux of his argument once
you get past the personal attack
you think this is somehow related to
china with the mcconnell and he
remarried an asian woman
here's a quote you know trump literally
said this in this release he goes
likewise mcconnell has no credibility on
china because of his family's
substantial chinese business
holdings and he went in there to talk
about and in mcconnell's wife
yeah but he selected her to be part of
his cabinet so he knew what he was doing
he looked at her and he said yep you're
from china what's up let's do it yeah so
the rest of his quote was he will never
do what needs to be done or what is
right for our country where necessary
and appropriate i will
back primary rivals who espouse making
america great again so this this
but but he just won a re-election he's
going to be there for another what six
years how long you
i mean no he that this is a quote from
trump in here so what i'm saying about
mcconnell primary
rivals but mcconnell just re-elected no
what trump's saying here is where
necessary and appropriate i will back
primary rivals
who espouse making america great again
in our policy of america first so
he's saying you know mcconnell disciples
he's going to put money in to get them
out
like they're they're not good for the
republicans mcconnell disciples yeah so
you ask yourself is this trump trying to
flex a little bit and say i am going to
be impactful over the next few years
i am going to have a say in this next
election if i'm not running myself
i'm going to be the leader of this
republican party and i think that's part
of it
and then the last thing is you had to
ask yourself how's trump going to
communicate
without twitter and he did this all on a
release essentially that he sent to the
media
he'll figure out a way and he still got
his message out right who's got more
control
currently in the republican party
currently mcconnell or trump
well i mean mcconnell has it inside
washington d.c
but you have who's got the support i
don't know that'll we'll find out but
trump's got the base obviously he still
hasn't mcconnell's got his question
what do you think what do you think
about i mean i think i think i think it
all comes down to control
obviously it seems like mcconnell is
trying to get past the trump era and
return to normalcy if you want
uh trump's trying to stay relevant he's
trying to stay
influential whether he's just trying to
stay
stay relevant enough to have a good
position to run in 2024
or if he's trying to full-on become the
godfather of a new
republican party uh i mean we'll kind of
have to wait and see but
it seems like there's uh obviously an
argument there and trump
does still have money that he they
didn't use on the campaign i think it
was like a 100 billion or something like
that
renovate a few hotels no uh i think 30
billion or something these are the
things to do with the money this is uh
this is his campaign
that he yeah the warchest that he never
uh fully went into what's he gonna do
with it he can
he can he can promote campaigns for
rivals of uh
of mcconnell's p peeps uh just can't
build a hotel
no no yeah he can't he can't use it they
tore down his atlantic city because he
knows today you know
yesterday okay yesterday uh so this is
gonna be interesting if the republican
party ever wants to get back into
the good graces or in the white house
would you not think that trump and
mcconnell are going to have to kind of
work together on this
right i don't know if mcconnell is going
to be here that much longer maybe
but i think it answers a bigger question
too is trump going to be able to
communicate
now it's different than twitter where
it's non-stop and it's constant and
this was 622 words this statement right
how many words can you do on a tweet
right now this would take a few tweets
it would take a while so he's still able
to get his message out but it just
doesn't like
bombard the day and stop everybody in
their tracks i mean he might be able to
get one or two of these out a week
as opposed to every hour he's sending a
message like he used to
um a little segue here you know whose
opinion i would actually genuinely love
to have heard on this would have been
rush limbaugh's
respect to the to rush limbaugh he was
in the news
recently passed away at 70 years old it
was
was it lung cancer after a year long
he last year he received the
presidential medal of freedom
we're not going to go too deep on this
topic but this is a topic that he would
have a field day with mcconnell who's
been
you know outspoken for against for years
he was obviously a big trump advocate
uh he would have been an interesting
opinion on this but the mcconnell
trump battle is i think something that
will be continuing for the years to come
i don't think either of them are done
weighing in on uh
on everything that happened but
mcconnell was very clear he said trump
you did this you promoted the lies you
were the conspiracy theorist
you provided the fuel to the fire of the
insurrectionists who raided the capital
and i think that mcconnell at the end of
the day
um believes in institutions so it'll be
interesting to see
where that goes um here's a story right
here moving on
big short investor michael bury says
that
the tesla boom is remarkably similar to
the dot-com
and housing bubbles the hype around
tesla reminds michael bury
of the dot-com bubble of the late 1990s
and the housing bubble
of the mid 2000s he said in a tweet the
scion asset
management boss who has been a vocal
critic of tesla for several months
revealed in december that he was short
on elon musk's
company tesla tesla stock price has
rocketed more than 800
since the start of 2020 lifting its
market cap to north of 780
billion dollars of the idea that tesla's
lofty stock prices are self-fulfilling
because the business can issue shares to
fund its growth berry said
saw this same thesis many times while
partying in 1999 that's what burries
said
can you pull up a picture of michael
bury and then also of christian bale the
character
he played in the big short thank you
mario he says
michael berry says the last big short
got bigger and bigger and bigger too he
said in another tweet
enjoy it while it lasts he says finally
what do tesla
bitcoin and option gamma traders have in
common
it rhymes with rubble
like barney rubble that's bubble so
here's a picture of
michael bury and the character he played
in the big short um
the sandalwaren flip-flop you know guy
uh christian bale great actor by the way
but basically michael berry who does not
give interviews
he's does he's not really out there on
the scene over the last few months he's
like
all over the news these days going
against elon going against apparently
bitcoin
but he's betting against musk would you
bet against musk at this point i wonder
if he was playing the drums when he did
that wasn't he doing that in the movie
all the time
frantic energy with this guy by the way
you know how much he made
not from the movie or from the but but
actually from the big short from
shorting the housing how many billion no
he personally made 100 million
his investors made 700 million so i
thought it would be more than that too i
thought he was walking away with
billions in that thing when you watch it
in the movie
um i don't know you know he let's just
say this for me
everything you know in life is
scoreboard have you done something
before do you have credibility
this guy had some serious credibility
for what he saw that no one else wanted
to see
and clearly i think smart people they
were making so much money during that
housing bubble they wanted to ignore it
maybe in the back of their mind
um there were so many great movies about
the the
market crash and just the financial
crisis of 2008
man they're unbelievable but and that
was one of them so i i think you have to
pay attention to this i i don't think
you just like throw it aside like this
guy's a quack i don't think you have to
like take it
and say this is going to happen in a few
weeks it'll be interesting to monitor
because
that is an abnormal spike in a stock
price number one uh number two their
sales probably don't
justify that type of thing um there's
other there's gonna be a lot more
competition to tesla
so i think it's interest for a guy that
stays under the radar
screen as much as burry does he doesn't
like detention like this even though
they made a movie about his life and
everything but you don't
hear about him every day for him to come
out this aggressively
makes you just wonder is he obsessed
with this like he was the housing
crash and maybe he does have some
information but then you're battling two
extremely smart guys
elon musk might already be one step
ahead of him and i think maybe that's
the way i might be leaning
that elon musk is no um you know
fly-by-night guy that just happened
proven himself so i think i would be
leaning towards you know if it does take
a little dip it's okay
versus musk on the on tesla going long
or short who you get i just say
big short of the housing bubble versus
tesla stock price it's not going to be
the same thing
it's going to dip no question about it
he's probably got something to this
but i don't see this thing completely
going under like like uh
like you're do you have a different
opinion on this guy uh i think it all
depends on how
long is the time frame we're looking at
how long is how far out are we looking
because
i think obviously if you look at the
stock it's it's gone like a hockey stick
it's gone straight up in 2020.
even um even
elon musk tweeted at one point i think
this the stock price is too high in my
opinion
yeah uh so so and burry said something
about it is gonna get crushed like a
souffle
yeah so i think that was like the first
quote that he came out with a couple
months ago so
so definitely sledgehammer on a slew
flip no yeah that was
that's what elon said oh that's what
elon said and then okay then
brewery came out something about chamber
so that's right so uh so no so i think
that
obviously it's the but justifying if you
look at the earnings
if you look at the cars they're
producing and the value of the company
like it just doesn't match up so
it's a lot of it i think is is hype
stock in a sense if they're just
on projecting on future earnings yeah to
one extent like obviously tesla's been
groundbreaking but i don't see it being
that crazy
um especially go ahead no especially
considering a lot of what they did in
the early on is a lot of the patents for
the cars are open
um meaning any volkswagen or anyone can
go in and
and borrow the patents and and implement
the technology in their cars as well
because test elon musk's main vision
when he started tesla wasn't to create
the biggest
car company in the world it was to start
the transition from fossil fuel to
battery and i think we can all agree
seeing
by 2030 range rovers done with
electrical with gas vehicles
so i think we can all agree that he's
won no he could stop right now mission
accomplished
exactly there's no going back we're not
suddenly in five years we're gonna from
now gonna be like ah screw electrical
vehicles we tried that it was a fad
thing where we're going to have change
change exactly right i mean very
powerful words right there just like we
talked about with the uh synthetic beef
just like we talked about the uh
electric yeah and everything everything
so i mean listen here's here's my two
cents right here the
the the in the in the 90s what you were
you born bro
98 98 ridiculous ridiculous i was
graduating high school at that point
um he wasn't even alive he wasn't even
alive
for the last dance of michael jordan you
weren't even alive you weren't even
alive the last time michael jackson
that's like us watching something on
world war one when you're looking at the
last dance that's so secular
i have an appointment on this adam i
have an appointment yeah well let me
finish my point here and then
i'll switch it over to you the the dot
com bubble if you had any company that
just
ended with dot com people were willing
to give you millions and millions of
dollars like
cuban yeah broadcasting.com
anything.com.com so
it was a house of cards same with
literally
the housing market in 2008 there was
just a lot of
bad fake mortgages unqualified you know
no uh
asset no income all that nonsense
so he's comparing tesla the price of
tesla to two basically house of cards i
think it's fair to this say
maybe tesla its price is a little
overvalued but the company is not
a house of cards so i think it's an
unfair analogy right there so
i understand that the comparisons he's
you know for someone who doesn't want
his name in the news
he's putting himself out there he's
drawing that analogy right there
so will tesla go down kind of like what
you said how long would the time rise in
there yeah it might go down
but the backbone of the company and the
idea and the leader of the company
clearly is on the right side let me ask
you guys a question or mario you do your
point and then i'll throw a question
because
my question is what if elon said i want
to put more time
into spacex into digging tunnels and he
stepped away from tesla
what would that do to the stock price if
he wasn't day to day
and he backed off a little i think that
would be bigger than anything probably
well he's propping up a lot of companies
just by tweeting stuff so yeah i mean if
you step down like kind of like how
gates stepped down i'm sorry uh
bezos stepped down from amazon what
would happen to the stock price at tesla
mario
no uh somebody in the comments and i
lost it so many comments on there but i
agree with adam in this sense because
it there are very different scenarios
there are different companies in the
sense but
the keywords for me are remarkably
similar but
similar in terms of what he's seen in
the economy
market what's not similar to me is the
individual
and i don't like to bet against a
visionary you know i wouldn't bet
against an elon because we've seen his
character
and i'll never forget the quote i've
heard about if you want to test a man's
uh
character give him power well elon musk
is sitting on some
pretty big checks right now he's sitting
with a lot of power what are we watching
him do
right so that's that part of it the
other part is um you're right with the
housing stuff you had a lot of fraud you
had a lot of
crappy leaders you had some executives
at the top that just dirty
the kind of people that you don't want
leading companies and they destroy the
market at that point
i agree you know i do think elon is kind
of like that tony stark individual so
i wouldn't bet against you you're saying
you're saying to your other point
money doesn't change you money exposes
who you really are
it enhances who you already are exactly
yeah exactly by the way best movie to
watch
on the housing crash and just the whole
2008 financial meltdown is margin call
have you ever seen that movie
the cast in that movie is so phenomenal
demi moore
um jeremy irons uh kevin spacey
kevin kevin space it is a phenomenal
movie
everybody if you haven't seen that one
check that out
all right let's get on to the next topic
but uh good stuff right there all right
so let's talk about two
towns or cities or states that are
trending certainly
in different directions here we go we're
talking about obviously new york city
and then our previous home state
of dallas texas uh manhattan and
brooklyn
new lease signings surged in january
both boroughs had the most new leases
during the month of january since 2008
since
right before the housing crisis the
number of leases
of new leases signed in manhattan are up
from january last year meanwhile
brooklyn had a
46 increase from january 2020. so both
boroughs are up almost 50 percent if not
a little bit more
um where's the rest of the story hold on
bear with me guys
tell you what i wasn't expecting to hear
these headlines about what's going on
here we go here we go here we go both
boroughs have seen increases
in new lease signings which does not
include lease renewal so new leases
because of the continued decline quote
unquote because of the continued decline
in net effective median rent record
concessions
and high vacancy aka rent prices are
going down
throughout the course of the corona
virus pandemic new yorkers have been
fleeing the big apple don't we know it
to live in suburbs and other states wink
wink florida
all together and because of that flight
rental prices go down this is supply and
demand this is economics
101. median rental prices in manhattan
are down 16 percent compared to last
year
and median rental prices in brooklyn are
down 13
so basically rent went down because
people were moving the hell out of their
supply and demand
the enhanced affordability here's a
quote right here the enhanced
affordability caused
a surge in new lease signings since
september as tenants
move around the city looking for better
deals your bitman you're bopping you're
moving around looking for a deal
and inbound migration has expanded
kai i know we talked about this
yesterday how much does it cost to rent
a one
bedroom in new york city so the most
expensive city in the country so we
found
on average uh the number was two
thousand three hundred and seventy five
dollars for twenty four hundred bucks
yes that's right now
that was uh i believe that that's right
now yeah and that was the twi
and what was it last year we saw there
was a 21 decrease from last so
right now you're talking about 27 2800
bucks for a one bedroom in new york city
you're paying almost three grand okay so
new york's making a comeback
is that what's happening right now is
this a good sign the pandemic i mean
what's happening in new york it's a
great sign i mean we need new york to be
strong not everybody can move to palm
palm beach county
all right i just drove through it we're
here in palmer you went to boy and you
were with the boca you would drove back
yeah i mean there's not enough room for
everybody to come to palm beach and and
worth avenue isn't big enough for
everybody to shop on that street as
opposed to fifth avenue
i think this is great this is
encouraging i mean it's depressing to me
to think that new york
was struggling the way it was i went to
new york in february right before
pandemic yeah and literally right yeah
literally right before and just walking
around
um times square and and broadway and
everything packed no
no i can already sense a little change
last year garbage was you know
everywhere and that's just leadership in
that city that we could go on about de
blasio
but we need america to be strong i mean
excuse me for new york city to be strong
you know it would destroy the country if
new york were to
you know continue to you know decline
like they were last year it's still the
hub for
advertising for finance and and for a
lot for media and for a lot of major
important things
in this world so i'm excited to hear
encouraging news like this
exciting new york making a comeback are
you ready to move to new york what do
you got kai
uh let's let's do it no i think uh but i
definitely think i agree with tom in the
sense that it's uh good news
because obviously it's it's a turning
point uh because all the other stories
we've been talking about new york is
them leaving
this person left that person left that
company moved this company one of my
closest friends
who moved down here from new york he
said every single one of his sin of
single friends moved to south florida
every
single one he said all the married
people with kids they stayed there yeah
they struck it out you're a little more
tied down you're more established you
know you're living in long island
whatever but he said every single one
they had the opportunity to move
he's like yeah they're all down here in
miami they're out there they're on
brickell they're out in south beach
they got the hell out of there yeah but
it seems like a year later almost
reality's setting back in new york new
york's not dying i mean jerry seinfeld
did a big thing like
new york ain't going nowhere okay don't
bet again but that was more a pep talk
that he was given at the time because it
was going somewhere it was going south
and he kind of needed he almost sounded
like he was delusional saying that
but this is good a positive sign like
this can only have ripple effects for
the rest of the year well i'll tell you
what man
if you told me a year ago one year ago
because usually in the summers so i've
been doing the remote work thing like
before was like
wfa work from anywhere wfh work from
home i've been working from home working
from anywhere for like
almost 10 years now like like people
have been wondering how do you do that
like remote thing
before it was you know in vogue right
now and i said so everything before the
word
or expression was invented oh before
you've been born bro four hour work
or even bore exactly and so usually in
the summers
i would um at well at one point i was
dating a girl from london so i would
spend some time in london we'd do the
europe thing
but i always love new york
so if you told me a year ago and i would
spend summers in new york as well
if you told me a year ago where will you
be living
during this pandemic this summer and
the options were new york city or
addison texas i would have been like bro
it's not what you even freaking talking
about everything
changed things have changed things have
changed as a pandemic
so it's good to see new york city making
a comeback i mean save that money move
around find a spot that you know
things are shooting i mean
vacancy is down or vacancies up so i
mean it's it's uh yeah but crime's up
and that's what they got to get their
handle on i mean crime is way up is
crime up in new york really
oh yeah yeah la big
time mm-hmm la big time okay thank you
sam
all right so shifting gears here we're
talking about new york city now let's
talk about
texas what the hell is going on in our
former home state of texas
so more than 2.8 million texans are
without power as the state
battles an unprecedented winter storm
well the entire country is
battling a winter storm but it seems
like texas right now is the porsche
child for what the hell is this weather
is doing
so frigid temperatures in texas are
causing a surge in electricity demand
and leading to rolling
power blackouts across the countries
across the country's second largest
state which prompted
president joe biden to declare a state
of emergency
in texas earlier this week at least 2.8
million texans have experienced power
outages as of 2 pm local time
that was monday when hurricane harvey a
category 4 storm
made landfall in texas four years ago
almost 400 000 texans lost power
so look at those numbers 400 000 during
a hurricane
and now almost 3 million
right now in texas the national weather
service tweeted
early monday morning earlier this week
that the temperature at its base had
reached
minus 2 degrees fahrenheit the coldest
temperature recorded in over 32 years it
is currently
negative two degrees fahrenheit
in texas we got out just in
just in time kai what the hell is going
on in texas bro
no i definitely think this is crazy um
and last time they recorded
temperatures like this i think it was in
1930s and then
right around 1900 so i mean obviously
it's unprecedented if we see here what
mario pulled up
um texas uh top area with by outages
496 000 homes you're looking at uh as of
last night
2.7 million people were still without uh
power
which is just wild now why taxes
in taxes now why is this happening uh
from what i've been reading
it's a lot of that texas is on its own
power grid
and that power grid has been having
issues uh and
given that it's its own system they
can't just lend excess power go
coming from other states the same way as
normally
yeah if this happens in another state
they can like take in
power from another state they come in
and help they can't do it they're
isolated in texas they have their own
grid so we always hear stories about
texas is going to secede from the union
yeah texas is his own republic
texas to do what it wants not today
what's up now texas
like it wasn't as easy it's not like we
we always hear stories i
i haven't heard that in a long time so
where where do you hear these stories
where do you hear what stories wants to
explain what do you mean this was like
the story like
we covered this on the podcast again i
don't hear that often but it does come
up but i don't hear that often
this one we covered this did we not
cover this on the pot this what was the
big story in the news about texas a few
months ago
right before the election possibility of
succeeding they were thinking about it
governor abbott
one time are you defending texas
i'm defending today i'm a former texas
but you're a florida boy now you enjoyed
this 80 degree weather okay you want
i'll show you a few months i will ship
you back to texas
negative two degrees there'll be a
guatemalan in texas with no
boots on he'll have a scene no boots on
the ground i'll have a scarf
did you guys hear what uh what elon musk
tweeted so the uh the texas electrical
grid operator
is called electric reliability council
of texas the e-r-c-o-t
and elon musk tweets out they're not
earning that r
for reliability because all the power's
out um not exactly an endorsement but
this is a serious serious issue
i mean i i i wonder how many people have
died i mean i
i feel old people how are you checking
on old people in this i mean i don't
know
your uncle
burning fireplace so they're okay they
could crank up some heat
um you know tesla's i i guess you show
some images like actual images of what
dallas looks like or houston looks like
of what houston had snow
the snow i mean this is on we never see
something like that i remember
one time because i was living in texas
in dallas from
one afternoon one sunday afternoon and
started snowing yeah and as soon as it
came it just melted
but i was like what's going on here this
is what texas looks like right now yeah
this looks like it's freaking
minneapolis right here tom's hometown
right
looks like it's minneapolis look at this
look what that's tigran's backyard
yeah and the problem in a city like
texas ring valley road that's right by
the office belt line literally
beltline road i lived on beltway road i
i
you know what i did you know this this
might have helped um
keep people warm i left my apartment i
burned that [ __ ] to the ground
i said i'm out of this apartment i will
never be at this a building again
vvv and m they're coming after me for uh
they actually pulled off they built a
soy man
a snowman a soy man nice well played
well played
but but bottom line is we are thinking
about our friends in texas
yep genuinely we're thinking about all
our friends
at php we're thinking about uh you know
people who are suffering through this
definitely cold weather right now and
we're rooting for it
wholesale price of electricity in
houston went from 22
a megawatt hour to 9 000. yeah their
natural gas supply has been cut off and
imagine
your home and your power goes off for 10
minutes you freak out
so my hearts are with everybody in texas
that are dealing with this right now i
hope it gets turned around quickly
i hope they can fix this reliability
grid that they have because it it has in
the issues because
at some point this weather will return
and you just can't have this
not in a state as progressive as texas
it if so many lives and plus when you
have snow like this
these cities aren't equipped with snow
plows minneapolis can handle it
milwaukee can handle it infrastructure
dallas california yeah
it's impossible caught off guard caught
off guard and enough of the
the seceding talk all right we don't
want to piss mario off with that but
that was a one-time thing apparently
enough of this okay you know and you
wonder like elon musk sends out that
that tweet i wonder if he now granted
you know you just don't make a
fly-by-night decision say i'm moving to
texas you have to think that through but
this doesn't help the recruiting right
for the people that are moving to texas
yeah
i mean it exposes the fact that you know
what it says there is this house this
house is recruiting to florida you might
not look like the best state in the
union right now as of now
as of now wow guys we did it we got to
florida
well i i didn't agree yet i mean sport
is great i mean it's fine are you going
to say california you've been talking
trash about california california
we all know guys that was this is the uh
the bet david podcast
we are thinking of our fearless leader
and ceo patrick betdavid
we want to thank him number one we want
to wish him hey
comment here says 2 wants to secede adam
okay good i'd like to keep it at one
percent i'd like to give it a zero
percent i'd like to keep all 50 states
in the union anyway back to pbd he's
traveling right now
he'll be back i want to say later this
afternoon we'll check in with pat we're
thinking of him
um he was just came back from kentucky
or he's on his way back from kentucky
uh we want to thank pat for entrusting
us to be at the helm
yeah while he's gone i feel like uh
borah had said i'm the king of the
castle king of the castle right now
but we've had a good time uh final
thoughts here guys before uh we we
we uh shut this thing down yeah adam i
gotta i gotta say can you know this is a
tough job you don't just don't
sit in pat's chair there and it's a
tough gig so good job running the show
today thank you buddy
the show really flew in and good job
thanks for everybody to tune in
and you know i will just say this a
quick little plug you know a lot of
these stories
we cover every single day on vtpost.com
so if you like the topics here
we literally a lot of these ideas come
from the stories that we write on
vtpost.com our whole team here does a
great job with social media
so if you haven't discovered it yet go
there and then
take that next leap and become a vip
premium subscriber because we have extra
special content for you
a whole bunch of prizes a dollar a month
it's a dollar a month you're kidding me
and we cater this new site for people
like you that want
the facts they want the news they want
to be entertained
with their day so it's vtpost.com we
welcome you and if you haven't
discovered us yet come find us
and he's the editor-in-chief we got him
here he's on the show he's right here
and speaking of editor-in-chief we got
the young buck kai he used to be the
editor in chief of research
now your talent bro how does it feel
final thoughts being talent these days
no it's all good and it's all good we're
out here
we're holding on to your next thing okay
wait a minute
i just got a text from patrick but david
and he said are you ever going to make
your point on today's podcast here we go
that's right what's your point with that
well uh pat we love you we're thinking
of you thank you for entrusting us
to hold down the podcast pat will be
back so for anyone being like what the
hell is this soy boy freaking uh
guy doing on there i think there's one
thing that's for sure today
mafia won so the big winner today was
the sword by mafia that's right that's
right
anyway thank you guys for tuning in take
care
bye bye bye bye
you